Hello freaks.
Let me do these people that are hearing this right in that.
There they go.
That's it.
People waiting there like,
what the fuck,
dude,
it's late.
Exactly.
That's how it caused folks.
We don't,
we don't guarantee you we're going to start at a certain time.
It's relax.
Leave it on the background.
We're trying to get you to take it less seriously.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
carbonite.com thanksgivings almost here.
It's the busiest travel time of the year,
but did you know that about 12,000 laptops are lost every week at us airports
that sucks a fat one,
and if you're traveling,
make sure your computer is backed up with carbonite online backup.
It's nice,
it's easy,
it's idiot proof,
so that means someone like me can use it.
All you need to do is set it up and carbonite will automatically back up your
important computer files to the cloud and continuously,
no matter how many computers your business has or where they're located,
or you could do it as an individual.
You don't have to be a business.
Do this easy to set up with each computer and you get peace of mind that
computer firewalls are you computer files,
I don't know what that other word was,
but computer files,
what I meant to say are always safe.
I have carbonite.
We use it here on the podcast to back shit up.
It's super easy to do and if you go to Carbonite,
got calm today,
type in the offer code j r e and get a free trial,
no credit card required plus two bonus free months with your subscriptions.
That's carbonite.com offer code is j.
R.
E.
It's an excellent service and it's always smart to be backed up freaks because
just in case some important shit that laptop shit's real.
I know that girl that buy a brand new MAC book.
Seriously.
The second day she went to go travel and she put it in that thing,
that little slot where the magazines are left it there,
came back like 20 minutes later it was gone.
Not only that,
they never find those things.
Wink,
wink,
those fucks.
Not all of them,
but you know you are.
We're also brought to you by ting.com rogan.ting.com specifically Tang is a cell
phone service that uses a sprint backbone,
but they rent time on it and use their own rules.
It's a much more ethical,
easy,
simple and fair way of distributing cell phone service.
They,
first of all,
they'd have no contracts or early termination fees.
If you don't like it anymore,
you just get out and it's sprint.
It's a,
it's an excellent service.
It's not like it's some new startup that doesn't have a lot of towers.
They use all sprint service,
but they do it in a different way.
They give you credit on unused service if you use less than you thought you
would,
tank drops you down and credits you the difference on your next bill.
That's a beautiful thing.
I love that.
I love that a company says,
look,
people don't mind paying for stuff.
I think everybody's established that capitalism and its core idea.
Not as far as like the way our economic system is set up of course,
but the idea of I give you money for something,
I work,
I get money.
Like these ideas are pretty clean as long as there's morality attached to it in
ethics attached to it and businesses can choose to put in termination fees and
choose to make you pay more for Shit,
then you have to or two thinking choose to fuck you.
Basically.
That's what they're doing.
And when a company like tin comes along that's not trying to fuck you.
I like it because I think it gives people a better sense of what they're dealing
with.
It gives you,
you know,
you feel good about it.
You don't feel like you're getting fucked over by some big giant asshole company
that's just sucking money out of the world.
And if you have a sprint iPhone four or sprint,
iPhone four s,
you can port them over to ting right now along with bringing over the nexus five
it's part of a,
there their bring your own device offering.
So go to [inaudible] Dot ting.com and save 25 bucks off of any are there new
groovy phones or um,
or service rogan.ting.com we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com
that's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain and monkey kettlebells.
We have all kinds of crazy shit over at [inaudible] dot com and this Friday is a
big fat,
crazy black Friday sale or shit's gonna get poppin.
It's a very,
um,
it's a very big sale for on and every year and they go,
they go crazy with it.
There's a lot of serious money to be saved.
For instance,
I think a,
Hey,
let me give you,
the people are already slowed down like,
like lined up for black Friday at best buy black Friday is weird.
It's a very weird thing.
I'm not sure I agree with it as far as like,
I definitely don't agree with you like getting in line and waiting and stores
because I feel like what is your time worth?
Isn't it worth something?
It's one thing if you're ordering online,
but if you're waiting and then you're there with a bunch of other assholes where
there,
because it's an event and it becomes a game.
Yeah.
And it's not,
it's much cheaper.
Like if you go to best buy,
you're going to save an extra $30 and what it would be at Amazon and then you
know,
half these companies online,
you don't have to pay tax,
which,
so that $30 it could have just,
you know,
safe with no tax.
Yeah.
And meanwhile you're going to have to use that money to get your teeth fixed.
Cause someone's gonna fucking elbow you in the face while you reach for that
laptop.
They want,
people are crazy.
But on amazon.com um,
you know,
I love ordering Shit online because you don't have to do,
it's like I do,
like half of my shopping is on amazon.com.
Like it's,
it's,
it's so easy to order shit online,
but the idea of like going to best buy,
I don't want to do that unless something's wrong.
You know,
I don't want to go to a place,
I don't want to go to Fry's unless something's really wrong.
I need some shit right now.
Cause otherwise it's like fuck going.
That's one of the things I love about stamps.com and the,
those kinds of services.
Like I don't want to go anywhere.
I want to have to go to your place.
Why can't we work this out?
Or I do this at home anyway at on it.
We're offering 25% off of all supplements,
55% off,
excuse me,
15% off foods and 10% off fitness and packages,
plus an additional 5% of orders over 150 bucks and 10% of old off of orders,
over 250 bucks.
So for big orders,
it's like 35% of supplements and 20% off fitness equipment.
It's,
it's pretty powerful.
It's a serious deal.
And on it,
if you haven't been there for awhile,
we have a lot of new shit.
We try to carry new things every month that we find that we think are
interesting.
We just started carrying defense soap.
Um,
yeah,
I need to get that.
So I've been,
uh,
kind of bring you in some remind,
remind me on Friday and I'll bring it in.
It's,
or I'll bring it tonight and you can wash your mouth out with soap after you
tell your dirty jokes at the ice house.
A defense soap is amazing soap that works.
It keeps bacteria off of your body,
bad bacteria,
but it keeps healthy flora on your skin.
It's all natural ingredients like tea tree oil and eucalyptus oil.
And it smells good.
It's completely organic.
It doesn't smell like,
you know,
like I had,
um,
it was at a,
this deer hunting things weekend and they had like regular soap.
I wash myself with regular soap once and then I luckily brought defense.
So,
but me,
because for some people they have like stinky deodorant soap.
So you're,
you've basically washing yourself with a fucking a ball of like,
it's,
it's Cologne.
Yeah.
I mean it's fucking Cologne.
You can call it in,
call it deodorant,
soap,
all you want,
that shit's Cologne.
You're covering yourself with some shit that doesn't smell like you.
I know I have axe body wise and I have like a one that right now but I'm not
gonna throw it away but it smells like I'm Persian when I wear it for the first
hour.
I just,
I smelled like,
I have like really shitty like Polo Cologne on when I,
when I go out whack job.
But I am a refuse that stuff just for their goddamn commercial.
Why,
why you treat me like I'm not stupid.
I know that there's people that are that stupid out there would retire you
bitches.
Actually they probably know their target market because those are the only
people.
Dumb enough.
Excuse me Brian.
Pardon me to a order.
That shit I just haven't had like I switched to bodies washed with like the lone
wolf or Poof,
poof.
Well actually defensive cells body wash too.
Yeah.
I don't think we have it on [inaudible] dot com yet.
But if you go to um,
defense soap.com and know they have it,
cause he's sent me some before.
Yeah,
it's great stuff and it's healthy and there's like a lot of,
uh,
it all came out of wrestling because in wrestling a lot of people get bacterial
infections.
They get staph infections from their skin,
from getting scratched on the mats and then dirty mats and,
and also,
um,
ringworm.
Ringworm is pretty common and a lot of times people wash with antibacterial soap
and that's the wrong approach.
When you're doing that,
what you're doing is you're killing everything man.
The good stuff too,
it's like when you take antibiotics,
we have a real problem with overprescribing antibiotics.
Antibiotics are very useful.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean,
if you've got a staph infection or if you've got fucking Lyme disease or
something like that,
antibiotics could save your life for sure they're there.
It's an amazing invention of fantastic human minds.
But the reality is there's other ways to approach it and the holistic way to
approach is to keep your skin healthy and clean and keep the healthy bacteria
that actually fight off bad bacteria.
Keep that shit active.
That's why I've always preached the,
the benefits of probiotics.
I drink Kombucha tea every day and it's,
it,
it's,
I like the taste,
but there's these floating pieces of fungus in it that feel like an elephant
just jerked off in your soda.
Goobers it's like a soda,
a Beeri Soda.
He thing.
I remember Marin,
you know Marin,
who's a mark.
Marin is a clean sober and uh,
he had a Kombucha and he's like,
ah.
He tweeted on Twitter,
Hey,
am I drinking fucking beer?
Like,
what's going on here?
Because this is before the,
uh,
they started taking them out of whole foods.
Esther got drunk.
Remember she,
she doesn't,
she doesn't drink.
She had two of them and she was like,
oh,
I have,
I have right,
like slurring words and everything.
There's less than 1% alcohol.
She said she was,
yeah,
I don't buy that.
It's,
if it is more than one half of 1% now they have to market and it has to be sold
as alcohol because they were using bottles apparently that allowed them to
continue fermenting.
So if they had been on the shelf for a couple of months,
they've got stronger and stronger and stronger as time went on.
Fantastic.
For your health though,
amazing for your immune system,
it's really some special stuff.
Have you heard about fecal transplants?
Yes.
I'm not crazy,
but yeah,
they take poop and they put it in your butt because or in your colon,
like if you're,
you're lacking certain bacterial,
um,
uh,
you know things are supposed to live in your gut.
Back to gut bacteria like e Kolai actually intestinal flora.
Yeah.
Intestinal Flora is the nice way of saying it.
But save people,
save people like from serious disease from Shit that was,
sorry shit,
shit stuff that was completely uncurable in any other way.
It's like you're fucked the last worth a shit up your ass.
I don't know how they do it.
What they did,
they take it like it doesn't help anything.
I just wanted to film this.
It's really simple.
They just take something from someone who's got the the floor that they want a
little bit,
put it in the blender or you know,
at some hospital thing,
mix it up and squirt that right out.
You've heard of the vice documentary about poop line that Chinese or I think do
it where they make wine out of a kid's poop that's like seven
years old or something like that.
I have heard that and I've also seen where they boil eggs and p young boys.
P Virgin.
Virgin Boys.
Yeah.
They prefer like boys under the age of 11 or something like that.
Whoa.
Yeah.
The other day,
I don't know if it was vice,
but was the thing about people going around the streets take up the manhole
cover and they've got these big long spoons and they grabbed the stuff that's
caught in the filter.
Right.
And the strainer and it's all this like fatty,
gelatinous horrible,
like big Luger's.
Basically what it is.
And then they take it out to their plant in the countryside,
boil it down and sell it as cooking oil.
Oh.
And they estimated the 10% of the cooking oil in China.
It contains this stuff.
Oh my God.
Fuck that.
Yeah.
Brian Cowen was telling me that when he was in China,
him,
uh,
he was with his family and his mom said that when they were at this restaurant,
she noticed that they had pig sties underneath the building.
Right.
And she's trying to figure out what was going on.
And um,
Brian was like,
why are they living on,
in the building?
She goes,
I suspect that there the,
the sewage system here.
Okay.
And so in the heat,
the,
it's traditional method,
they had the,
well just the body heat of the animals and the China and other Asian countries,
they would typically have them,
uh,
under the house.
So it would heat the house
and sewage.
I have shit into the eager face of a pig.
Now that you mentioned,
how dare you,
do you know that Peter Listens?
They're here.
The peak was asking for it.
All right.
Oh,
this was,
no,
seriously,
this was on a long bus ride in Sumatra and Indonesia.
Right.
And you get,
you know,
it's one of these 20 hour bus rides and you stop and you know,
all the buses stop in the same place.
They got the quick food and the shitters big long line of shitters and I go up
and it's squat toilets,
right?
And it's just a whole no plumbing or anything.
And I look through the hole and there are all these pigs down there,
just look it up with shit all over their faces.
Oh my God.
And you just happily shit right in their face.
It was hard to relax.
But I,
you know,
I was traveling,
I had a certain urgency.
What the fuck?
Anyway,
we don't sell shit or pigs@ana.com but if you use a code name,
Rogan,
yeah,
you'll save 10% off any and all supplements.
And of course this week is the big black Friday sale.
And,
uh,
as I described,
a 25% off supplements,
15% off foods,
10% off fitness equipment and packages,
plus an additional 5% off all orders,
over 150 bucks and 10% off orders,
over $250.
So that's this Friday.
We're getting crazy at [inaudible] dot com.
Lots of new stuff in it on it as far as,
uh,
products like a digest tech enzymes and Zombie kettle bells to go along with the
gorilla and ape kettle bells on it.
One 80 a nutrient based rejuvinating drink mix designed to help your body
recover from jet lag or from getting your freak on.
And of course,
Alpha brain used the code name Brogan and save 10% or go this weekend.
Save a fuck load more.
All right.
Freaks.
Dr Chris Ryan is here and uh,
let's,
let's get this party rolling.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
When a man tells you that he's shit into a pig's mouth,
you look at him differently forevermore.
If you look at Bacon differently.
Well.
Um,
I've been,
uh,
I want to go a hunting pigs.
I'm going to do that soon.
I think I'm going to go and do that this January.
You ever written a Michael Pollan's essay about a hunting wild?
No.
Sonoma?
It's an excellent essay.
I think it might be in a,
the Omnivore's dilemma or maybe it was published separately.
I don't remember where I came across a noma is a big area for them.
Northern California is a huge issue with pigs.
Yeah.
In Spain,
they're wild boars all over the place and you know the wild pigs and domestic
pigs like wild boars,
like,
like the,
those,
those crazy looking eval boards.
They're the same animal.
The exact same animal.
Yeah.
Really?
No species different.
No,
no.
According to Steve Rinella,
it's the exact same l animal.
Steven Nela is without a doubt the biggest animal expert that I know.
He's the host of mediator that a hunting TV show.
We just got done hunting with him and Wisconsin for deer,
which are fucking everywhere.
Oh my God.
You know,
people that like worry about deer hunters and what deer hunting.
It's evil.
It's cruel.
Like the people have no idea how many do you have?
There are like these guys,
they're asking to kill deer.
Like they have to make no pressure days.
There's no predators.
Exactly.
There's coyotes,
which a kill the Fonz and they kill wounded animals.
I go down and gets wounded.
But man,
well I grew up in Pennsylvania where there are no coyotes.
Right?
So there were no predators.
There were like two mountain lions still in the mountain somewhere.
But uh,
there are everywhere.
Everywhere.
I mean,
I've hit four or five or in a car.
Yeah.
And I moved out of there when I was 17,
so that's two,
two years of driving.
My folks used to live in Harrisburg.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Mine too.
We couldn't drive at night.
He's driving now.
You better go 10 miles an hour because they were everywhere in their driveway.
And you know,
it might be your marijuana plants.
How dare those cons,
they ate flowers too.
They love roses.
Yeah.
Wow.
I had a crazy dream that I just remembered because of that,
that a,
I brought a bunch of roses in for Pete for a friend to eat and he was eating him
telling me how fantastic they were and I was just taking it for granted.
I didn't want to eat these roses at all,
but I got them for him.
But a strange train for Valentine's Day,
but it wasn't like roses,
like a bouquet with like the leaves and everything.
It was like a plate,
like a,
like almost like a tray that you would get like at Wendy's,
you know like,
well it's fast food trays stacked up with roses on it.
You served him man rose.
Yeah.
It was like,
hey man,
I got some roses.
You can eat these.
Like you said try.
They're fantastic.
And I remember trying,
I'm like,
man,
I don't get,
it sounds like American beauty.
It's a fucking strange dream man.
And to the fact that I just remembered it when you said that like deer eating
things to see what else we're,
we'll knock loose.
Yeah,
it's dreams are a motherfucker,
man.
They're so weird.
How,
like in the middle of the day like,
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That for my fucking dream.
Like why can't I remember that?
What,
what is the mechanism there?
Figured that out.
Yeah.
There's a chemical that your body,
your brain releases that are racist memories.
What is it?
As you're waking,
I don't remember the name of the chemical,
but there's another one that stops you from moving.
Right?
So you won't hurt yourself.
It disconnects your volition from your body.
And uh,
that's why you have those a night terrors.
You know,
where you're like,
you,
you hear someone come in but you can't move.
You ever have that?
That's what it is.
But it's really aliens,
Bro.
Could be ale.
It's fucking aliens.
All right man.
What is it with aliens and anal probes?
Well,
I think it's a bullshit.
That's what I think it is.
And I think people who are crazy or worried about their ass all the time worried
someone's going to put something in there.
What's the name of the,
of the singer who used to be married to the bike?
I'm sorry.
I've Lance Armstrong.
Sheryl crow.
You this Weird Sheryl Crow alien thing?
No.
Okay.
I may be the only person in the world who's ever noticed this,
but it all right,
she's got a record that came out.
Uh,
and there are two songs on the record.
There's one called a maybe angels,
and it's about the lyrics are like,
my bags are packed if they ever come for me,
you know,
I know my sister,
she knew Elvis.
And so all this kind of like,
it's sung from the perspective of someone who's waiting for aliens to come and
take her away.
Right?
And then there's another song on the record called Heaven's gate,
which is,
I don't really know what that song's about.
Months after this record came out,
the heaven's gate cult in San Diego all killed themselves because they thought
that there were aliens behind the,
the comment,
the Hale Bob comment that was coming to take them away.
They're on the same sneakers on,
and they were all wearing Nike's,
I think,
right?
Purple Nike's or something like that.
And you know,
one of the people in that sector was the nephew of lieutenant who roof from Star
Trek.
Whoa,
weird.
But anyway,
that happened after she released this record.
So what I mean,
that's pretty weird.
You got a song about aliens coming to take you away and another song called
Heaven's gate,
and then some is about that Warren Beatty movie that was really just were bomb.
Yeah,
maybe she was like a Warren Beatty Fan,
which I like that.
I've thought of that as an alternative hypothesis and she just have but cancer
too.
Oh,
she did?
Yeah.
She just likes survivor.
She had breast cancer,
I believe.
I don't think it was buck cancer.
Girls don't get bud cancer as much as they get broke camp breast cancer breasts
are apparently very vulnerable to cancer.
Yeah.
Well,
you know why?
Why?
No,
because the cells replicate much more often and much more quickly in breast
tissue than another tissue,
which makes sense because they have to in order to swell up and morph and become
milk bags.
Yeah.
Ovaries too,
right?
You think about ovaries there every month.
And I'll tell Barry cancer,
another very common cancer.
And it's,
I mean,
here's,
here's another angle on this that I'm working into this book I'm writing.
Uh,
you know,
think about how many times a woman menstruated before agriculture.
I don't want to,
he made me,
but how many,
so a woman came into,
uh,
you became fertile at 18 or 19 because they had low body fat.
So they,
they meant straight in later.
Now girls are menstruating at eight,
nine,
10 years of age.
But the sort of typical hunter gatherer human thing,
it starts around 18.
They'd be having sex before then,
but there was no consequences because they weren't obvious.
Obviating so they got roped in to sex as the track one.
I don't know about.
Well,
anyway,
so just
to,
to follow this line,
uh,
so they start having,
yeah,
sex,
they get pregnant.
They have a kid,
they breastfeed for two and a half,
three years typically.
Right?
So that's a period of like four years when they're not obviating because women
typically don't ovulate when they're breastfeeding,
especially if they have low body fat.
And then,
okay,
they start ovulating again.
They might opulate a dozen times,
they get pregnant again,
another kid and so on.
So you add it all up.
You find that a typical human before agriculture,
female opulate it may maybe between 50 and 80 or a hundred times in her life,
you look at it after agriculture and like now women obviously you late three,
400 times in a way,
sometimes a day.
Some of them,
some of them seem like they're on the rag all day on a weekend.
The whole life,
their whole life,
they're spent bleeding.
So that stress is women's bodies a lot.
Cause every time they go through that cycle is you say their breasts are
swelling,
things are changing.
What are they attribute this change in?
The amount of menstruating women do?
Is it just food?
Uh,
it's a higher body fat,
which gets them started earlier.
But it's also that women aren't,
uh,
aren't having as many kids and they aren't breastfeeding their kids.
So a woman in an agricultural society or now could have a kid,
kids on cow milk immediately
cycling again.
What's the numbers on people who breastfeed and people don't?
It was almost all of my friends whose wives had children.
They breastfed.
Yeah.
I don't know.
And you don't have to also think about how to judge it.
You know?
How long do they breastfeed?
I know one lady who didn't want to breastfeed because she didn't want her
nipples to get ugly.
Yeah,
yeah.
A lot of women.
Let's stretch it out or did it didn't do anything to my wife's,
but to some,
some people's names.
Well,
some people are more susceptible to stretch marks too.
Like I've met people that had a kid and it just wrecked their body.
I mean it looks like they were attacked by a bear,
you know,
like just claw marks all of their stomach and then you see some girls,
they have a baby and then like three weeks later they look like nothing even
happened to them.
Like it doesn't even make any sense.
That's genetics.
Genetics.
They vary substantially when it comes to the elasticity of skin.
Apparently.
Yeah.
You know,
you see that in mixed martial arts,
like some guys get cut really easy and it's not just the shape of the bones
that's been argued.
That's the shape of the bones around the eyes.
There's some people that just have much more tender skin.
There's guys like Bj Penn,
Bj Penn fought and like God,
I don't know how many times the champ have to weight divisions.
I've never seen the guy caught it,
never gets caught.
He gets beat up.
I mean he's had fucking wars,
five swollen,
no cuts.
It's weird.
Some guys you just,
you punch misses him and they cut open.
It's a very strange thing.
I think it goes that way with a vaginas as well.
Like some girl's Vaginas,
like snapped back into action and other ones it's like you just shot a bowling
ball through a chicken.
You know,
it's,
what are you going to do with this?
You're going to stitch up,
stitch up the outside and pretend you're not a fucking or canyon.
After that.
It's,
you know,
it's just genetics.
We were talking about Dan savage earlier.
He's gay,
right?
So he's not real into vaginas.
And at one point he wrote in his column that for him,
vaginas looked like canned hams that had fallen from the sky and I can split on
impact.
How rude.
He did not win him a lot of and
ratio from the ladies.
It's so silly to say too,
they don't look anything like that.
It's a shitty comparison.
Well,
you know what's he know,
but I mean it doesn't look,
I can't handle it fell from the sky at all.
No,
it looks like a strange gelatinous alien that's trying to steal your sperm.
That's what it looks like.
The mouth of some strange creature,
some succubus bus.
It's just there to pull genetic material out of your body,
which essentially the vagina is.
Other than being a point of pleasure in a place where Your pee looks like your
Predator mask.
That was in my last special,
I was talking about my wife saying that uncircumcised dicks are ugly.
And I'm like,
have you even seen your vagina?
Do you know what that thing looks like?
The extra skin on that might be the best one
part of it.
Yeah.
Genitalia,
you know,
it's all in the eye of the beholder.
Right.
He's gotta be in the mood,
especially if you're really wanting it looks better.
Yeah.
That's when it becomes delicious.
When you're all excited.
So,
um,
there's many things that have caused people to start menstruating later in life.
Yeah.
Primarily,
uh,
less,
breastfeeding less amount of time and higher fat diets.
What percentage of women breastfeed?
Yeah.
And you're going to want to look on,
you know,
cross cultural stuff too?
No,
I'm going to go with the first website I find,
and I'm going to say it like it's fact,
because that's what you do.
How that's how it goes.
The CDC Center for Disease Control,
they know.
Yeah.
They'll know about America.
Sure.
More mothers are breastfeeding,
but overall rates are still low.
90%.
Yeah.
Of families exclusively breastfeed for six months.
Wow.
How many?
90%.
And they're saying that's low.
Um,
they say they're saying that,
um,
overall the rates are still low,
is what they're saying in this article.
I don't understand.
That doesn't make sense.
It's on CBS news too.
What are you saying you fucks?
Did I read this wrong?
Is that possible?
You know,
in breastfeeding also relates to what we were talking about earlier with the
bacteria and the intestinal fallen and all that.
Babies that are born vaginally pickup,
uh,
bacteria,
especially skin bacteria that stays with them for life.
Whoa.
And they found that babies who are born through society and don't have that and
are more likely as a result to get infections and various fungal infections and
their skin's,
wait,
I got proceed.
Bacteria on me.
Yeah,
you want to,
you want to get as much of that as you can.
And then a breastfeeding as well.
The first few days of breastfeeding,
I think it's called clostridium.
There's a substance that comes from the breasts that isn't,
it's mostly stuff other than milk.
Really high colostrum.
Colostrum,
I think that's the word.
Yeah.
He just spit that out.
Like you know what you're talking about.
You don't know how to say it,
but I know what it tastes like.
You get an order that you could buy it at a whole foods.
I'm past,
the old from cow
is healthy.
It's rich in human growth hormone or cow growth hormone.
It's very similar.
So with this,
listen to this statistic,
this is pretty crazy that they're not saying how many people do it.
What they were saying was if 90% did,
this is how much lower uh,
health risks.
Right?
Right.
I can't read and talk at the same time,
but infants who are breastfed for the first six months have a 72% lower risk of
hospitalization for lower respiratory tract infections and it's 64% reduced risk
for non-specified gastronomical tract infections,
58% risk reduction for the intestinal infection.
Necrotizing enter.
Wow.
Enter ocular Titus in preterm infants and at 27 to 42% reduction in allergic
diseases in breastfed infants.
That's amazing.
You would be an asshole to not breastfeed your kid if you could because you're
like,
setting this up,
this kid up for like a life of much more likely infections,
much more likely allergic reactions.
I mean,
those are big numbers.
Yeah.
And that's just the stuff that happens when it's still a kid.
There's evidence that there are lifelong changes in immune response.
Whether uh,
based on whether or not a kid was breastfed,
the World Health Organization recommends that babies should be exclusively
breastfed for the first six months of life and then receive a combination of
breast milk and easily digestible foods through the age of two.
Wow.
You should still have breast milk up to the age of two.
Research shows that if 90% of families exclusively breastfed for six months,
almost 1000 infant deaths could be prevented annually and 13 billion would be
saved in medical costs each year according to the u s department of Health and
Human Services Office on Women's health.
That's amazing.
I mean,
I know there's some issues that some women have,
some women's,
um,
areas aren't set up for breastfeeding and some of that can be helped with pumps
to apparently,
and you know,
some people,
they just don't have the fucking time,
unfortunately.
And also it's a social thing.
You know,
in the United States it's still seen as a shameful,
you know,
sorta something you should do in the bathroom.
There states where it's illegal to do it in restaurants or in public.
It's,
there's a lot of bullshit women have to contend with in addition to the
biological stuff.
Yeah.
Doing it in public as a rough one and the same.
That's like everywhere in India.
Women are breastfeeding,
but those are Spanish,
tits and Indian to it's no one cares.
You know,
you got a nice American corn fed tet and you can't just have that out there in
the breeze.
I sat next to one on a plane just last week on the way home from Vegas and the
whole time I just had my sunglasses on staring at her nipple all the time.
It's great.
You're a fucking creep.
Which are the reason why Pete?
No,
I wouldn't.
I'd be respectful.
You're the reason why people are afraid to do that.
Fuck wait,
was,
was this a fed or
stupid?
Ma'Am,
why don't you do that?
Because she was hot.
You're just being an asshole.
Okay.
Anyway,
more than 70% of American women don't fall the new recommendations.
So that means that 30% of women breastfeed.
That's,
that's crazy.
this is,
so this is a more accurate statistic as to how few actually breastfeed.
70% of American women don't exclusively breastfeed their babies for the first
six months.
So they might be mixing formula.
And with that,
I'm not sure,
I'm not sure how it works,
but that's not good.
You,
you ever heard about what Nestle did in Africa?
No.
If the formula they had a bunch of formula was um,
it was too old,
it was expired.
They hired guys to go around Africa wearing like lab coats looking like doctors
trying to convince women to use this formula because they were gonna just go
throw it away.
So they sold it and really cheap in Africa.
Now these are women who otherwise would breastfeed,
which is really good for their kids.
Right?
But because these guys are wearing lab coats and you know,
speaking with authority in this,
all this scientific bullshit,
a lot of women,
tens of thousands of women started buying this formula,
mix it with the really shitty water that they've got there.
And all these babies die all over Africa.
And Nestle gotten big.
It's just like in the eighties or nineties,
there was a worldwide boycott of Nestle because of this is
it's corporations.
It's the idea that you have to make money for your company,
period.
Did you see today with the,
the Supreme Court agreed to hear a case to decide whether or not corporations
have religious rights.
They've already determined they have the right of free speech,
which is translated into unlimited spending on political parties because that's
considered speech citizens United.
And uh,
now today they agreed to hear a case because these companies that are owned by
religious radical right wingers don't want to have insurance for the employees
that cover birth control.
So they say it's their right as a corporation not to do this,
even though it's the national law and the Supreme Court's going to hear the
case.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
I mean,
when people talk about Frankenstein,
you know,
this whole idea like,
or will will robots ever take over?
It's like,
dude,
it's done.
Yeah.
Look at a corporation is something we created,
legal structure that we created that has already got more power than governments
or religions.
It's taken over governments.
You even if you talk to people,
they say,
yeah,
but there are good people in that company.
Sure there are,
but the company doesn't give a shit.
Right.
Cause they'll die and they'll have new people.
It's like it's like a structure that has taken control of the planet and we're
just part of the structure where like working for this monster.
Yeah.
It's all about ones and Zeros and when it comes down to only being responsible
for your bottom line and having an obligation to shareholders to include
increased the money every month,
that that gets really weird because it is sort of a machine and it's each person
has to go home and say,
Hey,
what can we do?
It's business.
It's what we do,
right?
Like what?
What are,
what do we do?
We're plugged into this weird machine and what are the machines doing as best I
can tell their entire purpose is taking part of the earth and turning it into
shit.
You know,
like destroying everything that's beautiful and,
and digging big holes and turning it all into plastic that then floats in the
ocean.
Some you know and when you're involved in the manufacturing process?
Most except for Ting Tang is really corporations,
sort of a company kind of.
I've got to say last time I,
one of the Times I was on your show,
you were talking about ting and I had an iPhone.
I don't know if you remember and I was like,
damn,
I would get Tang if I didn't have this fucking iPhone,
but I got so like tired of bullshit with phone companies like the hidden charges
and the sneaky bullshit and I really admire this,
this philosophy of like,
hey,
here it is.
You get what you pay for.
We're not going to fuck around with you.
I ended up selling my iPhone.
I got a Samsung just so I could go with tink for you.
Which one did you get?
A galaxy s four it's a nice phone.
Yeah.
I saw you went with the the other one that this bad boy.
That's a monster.
The note.
Oh,
you got to know it.
I thought you got the note three.
You had another one a few months ago.
I got an HTC one.
Yeah.
This is the shit though.
This was the one I really love.
Still using it.
Oh yeah.
I love the fuck out that phone set up.
The little pen.
Yes,
a stylist.
I write my comedy notes on it.
Like I don't need to bring a notepad with me anymore because I have an endless
supply of pages and I can file them on the phone.
Like I can shuffle through all my notes.
I put them in folders.
It's amazing.
I got to stop coming on this show.
It costs me money.
Every time I got to buy a new phone I'm going to have to go buy a note and get a
Porsche.
Well the um,
the galaxy s four,
it's pretty sweet.
It's sweet.
Another phone.
It is beautiful.
I mean just the screen looking at photos and say I don't watch videos and stuff
on the phone,
but I like looking at the photos and man like go back to an iPhone after that.
It looks so small and the Internet is the biggest difference in the experience.
You mean cause this,
the note is enormous when you're looking at screen.
If you're looking at a photograph on the screen or if you're looking at a
website,
I mean God damn huge.
I mean look how big that is.
Yeah.
I mean it really is like a tablet.
You get an awesome view and you know,
I carry a purse.
How dare you immerse.
I like it.
I wish everybody did.
Yeah.
So you can take rule for that and yeah,
I put it in my back pocket.
It fits easy.
Oh really?
That's no issue at all.
But uh,
I'm 100% in favor of the murse.
I think I'm disgusted by the fact that we can't wear a purse.
It's rude and we just have to take back,
take it back.
I consider it more than immerse.
I consider it my quite chain Kane bag.
Remember?
Remember quite chain cane?
Yeah,
I do Kung Fu.
Yeah.
He had a bag.
He had like a little leather sandbag.
Yeah,
little leather thing.
He kept as necessary.
I tried keeping my laptop one of those cause I wanted to look more
sophisticated.
I feel like I'm in my forties now.
She'll probably grow up.
I didn't work.
I went back to the backpack backpack.
She was more effective.
Wait for your fifties I give up.
I just got this new shirt like a,
it's like a Hoodie.
I don't have it on right now,
but it has like a man like a fanny pack built into it kind of.
You have your two hands in your pockets and then there's like this middle like
thing that's just like a fanny pack.
Yeah,
it,
yeah,
it's like velcro.
You just open it up and it's not the hundreds like a baby step.
That's the gateway drug to fanny packs.
Yeah,
it's cold.
Cause I use it like crazy and it just looks like you have a little,
you know,
stomach of gear and then some,
some girls like guts,
you'll find them that way.
It was girls other than have fetishes,
just like guys,
like pretty feet.
Some girls like guts.
Really?
Yeah,
I've heard.
Not enough of them.
It's an evolutionary advantage.
There's more guts out there.
So they start,
they start gravitating towards in order to ensure that their seed gets spread.
Right.
And a lot of the guys with the guts have money.
Yeah.
I think a lot of people have given up on quality and they just,
you know,
just want to get the job done and any port in a storm got her warm.
Well,
physical attributes are not nearly as necessary as it used to be.
When our society gets more and more safe,
you know it's less and less a requirement to be physically sound or strong or
not look like in a key little version.
Now they have life insurance policies.
It's actually beneficial if you marry that guy with a bad heart.
Exactly.
Ladies Kill when you will.
Yeah.
If you marry a guy who's got like sleep apnea,
he's a hundred pounds overweight and he's also on a gang of pills,
like just wait it out,
get a nice life insurance policy,
make sure the medical stuff is all documented.
He's going to kick over eventually.
How long can they last?
Get them involved in sports.
Say Yani,
I want you to start losing weight.
Let's go scuba dive and get them involved in some stupid shit you can't do that.
Ticker would just give the fuck out and then you rake it in hang gliding.
It's evolutionary,
right?
I mean there's got to be gold diggers have to be a part of evolution,
I mean it has to be some,
some form of an equation.
What is that a serious question?
Cause not really.
It's like what we were talking about,
like corporations being machines.
I did write a book about that.
It's like a
gold digging.
Yeah.
Well we,
we wrote in our book,
actually we say Darwin says your mother's a whore.
And I had business cards that I had that quote on the book because Darwin's
theory is that women traded sexual access for goods and services,
right?
Gold diggers essentially.
And the sort of mainstream views since Darwin has been that that's women's
nature and that man's nature is to be the provider.
And so the women are trying to rope in the best provider and all that,
but that we basically call bullshit on that in our book.
So how do you call bullshit on it?
What's the,
well,
you know,
aside from
all the evidence that our ancestors did not evolve in nuclear families,
uh,
in our bodies and in our,
you know,
the,
it's 300 pages of evidence.
But essentially what we say is,
no,
we may have sex for the same reason men do.
It feels good.
And it's a way to bond with somebody.
It's not about getting something from the dude because when you actually look at
hunter gatherer societies,
hunters go out of their way to make sure that nobody knows who killed the
animals,
like the hunters will,
uh,
exchange arrows and stuff before they go hunting.
The guy who brings the animal back to the village often generally is not the one
who killed it.
There are all these,
um,
very powerful,
uh,
ways that societies make sure that nobody gets proud and nobody gets too much
credit and everything's spread around evenly.
It's fierce egalitarianism is what the scientists call it.
And it's not because they're,
they're,
you know,
a noble savages or some shit.
It's because that's the best way to mitigate risk in a hunter gatherer society.
All right.
So like you go hunting today,
you hit,
you get a deer.
I didn't get one.
I might not get one for a week.
Right.
But you're not going to get one everyday.
It's sporadic.
You come back,
you don't have any refrigeration anyway.
So it's not like you could keep it all for yourself and your wife and your kids.
Right.
And uh,
and it mitigates risks.
What everybody eats,
you know,
whether you get it or I get it.
We all eat.
Plus we're all really highly independent,
interdependent.
So the last thing we need is you and me fighting over who's a better hunter and
you know,
who's fucking,
whose wife and all this kind of bullshit cause that splits up the group.
So we are you in sex at dawn is the human sexuality was actually a way to bond
the group together and people were having sex with different people
simultaneously and raising children together.
And this obsession with paternity,
which is assumed to be part of our DNA,
is actually a response to agriculture,
which is just 10,000 years ago,
which is like 5% or less of our existence as a species.
So is there a response to staying put,
which allowed people to make much larger civilizations?
Yeah,
yeah.
In,
in a nutshell,
essentially it was when people stayed put,
they could accumulate resources,
right?
Whether it's domesticated animals or land or buildings or wheat or whatever.
And so once that happens,
then there's a completely different sense of property,
right?
Because in a hunter gatherer society,
there's very little property cause they're nomadic,
so you don't want to carry shit around,
right.
And,
um,
whatever there is,
is shared.
And uh,
when you shift to agriculture,
suddenly there's a lot of property and it's not shared.
It's,
it's hoarded,
it's controlled by individual families or people.
So that's when paternity becomes a big deal because you've spent your life
accumulating all these resources.
You want them to go to your son's right.
And it's also interestingly,
the first time that people really understood that sex caused babies.
Because before that everybody's just having sex and women are having babies.
There's no reason to think that sex is causing the babies.
Wow.
But then when you've got domesticated animals and you see like,
oh,
okay,
the black bowl,
fuck that white cow.
And now we've got these black and white calves.
Oh right.
I get it.
Right.
So you start putting that together when you're living around a lot of
domesticated animals and breeding.
And so that's when women became the property of men.
If you read the Old Testament says,
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife frame property.
Yeah.
It's not about respecting his marriage,
read it in context,
nor his house,
nor his ox,
nor his slaves.
Nor has she asked you in whatever she asks us.
So it's the,
you know,
keep your hands off your neighbor's stuff and the wife is just part of his
stuff.
So that's radically different from the way men and women interacted in hunter
gatherer societies where women had very high status equal to or sometimes higher
than men's because of the women's supplied a over half of the calories that
people lived on.
Alright.
The gathering is what brought the food in every day.
The hunting was an occasional bonus.
So the women were involved in plants and harvesting fruits and vegetables and
things.
Small rodents.
Yeah.
So Maul Rodents,
ladies take care of the small rodents will go get the mail cook.
He can't handle anything too large.
So they,
because of they brought in small rodents,
they were the kings,
that kind of thing.
Well they,
you know,
they were like,
mom,
you know,
they were there day in,
day out.
Dad's like,
hey,
you know,
like occasional party dad brings home a deer or something.
But wow,
that's interesting.
How do they know this?
For sure.
Well,
you look at Wa which aspect?
Yeah,
the whole story and being,
you know,
having a,
the higher status,
um,
matriarchal in that case,
primarily you're looking at anthropological research that's been done by people
on hunter gatherers.
Right.
There's still some hunter gathers in the world and in the sixties and seventies
there were a lot more and a lot of people wrote their research on that.
So there's a pretty sizable research on hunter gatherers and what you find is
universalities.
So whether you're talking about in wits in Greenland or Australian aboriginal
people or Papa New Guinea or the Upper Amazon,
you find these similarity or or universalities among all the different groups.
So you say,
okay,
look,
if they're all,
if this is common to all of these groups from all over the world,
then it is a characteristic of hunter gatherer societies and we know our
ancestors were hunter gatherers,
so therefore we can extrapolate.
Wow,
that's interesting.
So what about money?
How did that factor into it?
Because when you started not just accumulating material possessions but actually
start figuring out finances and figuring out money and the monitoring
compensation for work and things along those lines,
like how did that factor into the male female relationship?
Because men physically being stronger,
we're able to do things being more aggressive or probably push here when it
comes to acquiring that money.
And then they found themselves in an imbalanced position with the men have more
financial worth and the woman.
Yeah,
and the women generally have zero financial worth.
It's not just that the manners,
you know,
slightly higher.
You look at women in,
in societies like,
uh,
early agricultural societies and the Middle East and you know,
as recounted in the Bible and so on.
A woman's only access to the things she needs,
food,
shelter,
status,
things like that.
It's through a man,
it's through her father and then through her husband.
Well the Middle East,
they take it to the next level.
You can't even show your face cause you're the property of the man.
He doesn't want that being shown.
You're walking around the fucking tent over your head every day.
Some,
I mean that's the biggest that like you want to talk about like the weak ass
approach to life.
They can't drive like,
I mean,
in 2013,
Saudi Arabian women are battling to drive.
They're risking their lives to drive just to fucking,
they won't let him drive.
I mean,
it's like,
dude,
you guys gotta relax your grip.
All you Saudi Arabian men,
you're fucking yourself over like is no one taught you.
You know what,
what having character is,
is no one taught you what being a bitches.
Like what,
what kind of a man wants to keep his wife from driving and wants her to wear a
sleeping bag everywhere she goes,
let's you fucking ridiculous.
The idea is ridiculous.
She can't show her face like this.
He's got to go through life like she's a bank robber.
That's so fucking dumb.
In 2013 the fact that that still exists.
I mean,
what is that an echo of what,
what,
what caused all of that?
Cause the scarcity thing.
Well,
I think it's an echo of these early days when women became the property of men.
And,
and honestly,
you know,
uh,
with someone I was talking to recently,
just the tenor and American woman said in the 60s,
in the 60s,
she couldn't open a bank account without her husband or father co-signing.
The shoes are silly bitch,
she's going to go crazy with the money by person.
I don't think we have no money for baby formula.
I don't think so.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's not that long ago that we were,
we're still,
you know,
fucking women over in lots of ways.
But,
um,
as far as that,
you know,
the whole Middle Eastern thing,
I think that's a reflection of this notion that women are the property of men.
Now,
why were women the property of men?
Partly it's,
as you said,
questions of upper body strength than the way men organized politically more
effectively than women did.
And so men took control of a lot of stuff.
Also the need for armies because agricultural societies expand,
you know?
And that gets us into what we were saying earlier about corporations,
right?
That's when you get these institutions that were growth is a central
characteristic of that institution.
You know,
I think it was Edward Abbey who said growth for its own sake is the ideology of
the cancer cell.
It's also the ideology of corporations,
of agricultural societies.
You know,
we talk about growth,
right?
Oh,
this,
this year's growth rate is whatever,
you know,
everything's always got it.
Hundred thousand new jobs introduced by the president.
Exactly right.
What we need to be,
one of the things I'm talking about in this book I'm working on now,
it's called civilized to death.
Um,
is the whole idea of progress stops making sense.
If you're going in the wrong fucking direction,
if you go in the wrong way,
the last thing you want is progress.
You went regress.
We don't want growth.
You know,
we gotta go,
we got a contract.
Get fewer people.
Yeah.
Using fewer,
you know,
fewer resources.
I was a fascinating thing that transport Canada once said about a mushroom chip.
He asked a mushroom,
uh,
how could he possibly,
how could anyone possibly save the path that humans are on?
And they said very simply and very easily.
Each parent,
each,
each couple should reproduce.
Once you know,
two people,
they have one kid,
everybody relaxes the whole,
the resources relax,
everything.
Relax.
It's like there's plenty of fucking people.
Okay,
there is zero worry that people are going to go extinct.
But then the problem is how do you go to those people,
like those crazy people that were on that TV show that had 19 children,
none of those people.
First of all,
what does she,
what does she in labor for like three seconds.
I mean what,
what
does he actually have sex with her or does he just jerk off into the abyss?
Like how,
how,
how are those babies actually fertilized,
um,
that,
that woman,
how could you tell that woman she can't do that?
I mean I think it's a freak show.
I think it's,
I think resources wise,
like I have three kids.
It's hard.
It's hard to give them all the time that they deserve.
You know,
me and my wife have discussed that when it comes to the possibility of having
more children.
I said I think we should really concentrate on raising the ones we have.
Like their,
they're fun and it's great.
And I,
I,
they needed a lot of time,
like children need a lot of time and I enjoy giving them that time.
But I think that if you have another kid around,
everyone gets a little bit less time.
And I think in that getting less time,
there's some benefits,
the independence aspect of it,
as long as there's love and there's comfort.
But I also think you can teach kids a lot of Shit,
you know?
And you could teach them a lot,
especially if you really are into it and you concentrate on it and you read a
lot of books on it,
which I'm really involved in.
The idea of raising kids,
like I'm raising little human beings.
So the conversations that I have with them are all geared towards that.
Like it's geared towards enlightening them is to the world and it's sort of
guiding them is how to,
how to treat people,
how to be nice to be.
But it'd be nice to your sister or like be nice to [inaudible] Pete.
Don't,
don't get angry at things for no reason.
Look at it this way instead of that way.
And I think that kind of,
you know,
you ain't gonna miss a lot of that when you have 1516 kids,
you're going to like,
do you guys just shut the fuck up,
shut the fuck up.
Organize teams.
You,
you're responsible for your little brother you're responsible for.
And that's what those people did.
Those people have like every kid has a chore and every kid,
that's how you're raised as zombies.
I mean these kids,
they're not going to know what the fuck is going on in the world.
Like they're going to need someone to help them every day is spent doing tasks
and,
and your life is basically religion,
homeschooling and these tasks.
That's those kids.
That's the,
the 19 people.
What are they?
The Duggins?
Is that what they're called?
Yeah.
See if you will find that.
It's,
I mean,
look,
I don't think you could tell those people not to do that.
I think this is America,
but the Americans got it's faults.
But,
but the thing about it,
they only neutralize like eight gay couples neutralize when you want to.
I mean,
like if it goes to 18 kids,
you average it out.
Like you got eight gay couples,
it who don't have any kid.
And it's like,
or adoptive kid,
which takes it out of the other pool.
And you're,
you know,
mathematically you can have outliers like that because there are lots of people
like me who don't have kids,
you know,
and just,
I mean,
I think the way to do it is to remove the stigma around not having kids and to
encourage,
um,
w what Helen,
uh,
Sarah Hrdy calls aloe parenting.
And this gets back to the hunter gatherer thing.
Um,
like kids are raised by everybody,
you know,
they say,
Oh,
two parents are better than one.
Yeah,
that's true.
But you know what,
five parents are better than to write.
It takes pressure off you,
right.
Because you get frustrated,
you get tired,
you know,
their mother gets tired.
And it also,
it's enriching for the adult.
I love being around kids for a couple hours,
you know?
Right.
Yeah,
no,
I know.
I can fully,
you know,
we
had a party at my house,
the had day and uh,
there was uh,
a gang for Halloween.
There was a Halloween party and there was a gang of kids over and uh,
it was fine.
It was fun talking to other people's little kids and you know,
seeing how they're different and how they behave different.
They have different ideas about stuff and you know,
it's nothing wrong with that.
This is the,
the family,
the 19 folks that live at home together.
Nice House stuff for 19 guy must be making some good bank,
be paying for all those kids.
Maybe he just loves to fuck.
It's all this religion and stuff.
It's just to keep them all around.
Just love sending in
19 kids seems a little excessive.
But again,
I don't think weighs anal.
Not for really religious people.
I think it's in the Bible.
Oh really?
People pick and choose what they like about the Bible.
That's why they get religious tattoos.
Did you ever think that were you raised religiously?
Uh,
21,
that's a family of 21.
And there's this new one called the Bates family.
Oh God.
They're taking on the fucking Duggar's toxin a new,
they're still growing.
Look at that creative fucking the left.
Uh,
yeah,
I was really Catholic.
I went to Catholic school and uh,
I went only for one year,
but luckily my mom and my dad split up when I was about five years old and it's
like that old world,
New Jersey,
sort of Italian and Irish mix.
There was,
everyone was fucking Catholic and everyone went to Catholic school and,
but for me it was,
uh,
it was very enlightening.
I gave up on religion when I was six years old.
I gave up on religion in Catholic school.
I was like,
obviously this is not real.
Like this is very obviously not by him is I was like,
if there's a god,
and I wasn't saying that there was no god,
but I was like,
this shit is just crazy people.
This is just more crazy people that have figured out how to control a bunch of
assholes and scare
the shit out of him.
I could see that as a six year old at this crazy lady who is teaching this class
was just as an evil demented woman,
a hateful,
horrible woman who had nothing to do with what everybody told me God was about.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My parents were raised Catholic and that part of the country,
and I saw a lot of that,
but I was thinking recently like,
uh,
you know,
you're talking about anal sex and Christians and all that.
Uh,
I wonder if,
if we're sort of shooting ourselves in the foot,
those of us who are trying to,
uh,
you know,
move away from shame and hang ups and stuff.
I wonder if the people with the shame actually have better sex is because it's
intense.
No,
no.
You don't think like a priest fucking and none out behind the church and the
woods knowing God's watching.
You don't think that's like a really intense fuck.
No,
because I think you're dealing with so much guilt that neutralizes hate.
Useless fucking gross.
It's one of the worst feelings you can ever feel.
You know?
I mean,
I think there's,
there's reasons for it.
It's to guide your behavior in a way that you don't have any guilt,
but it's also you can get fucked over and create associations very early on
about things he really shouldn't be guilty about like masturbation,
right?
Like someone was telling me,
hey,
you know,
man,
you should cover your camera on your laptop because there's a camera on the
laptop and the fucking NSA spying on you.
And I'm like,
good.
They'll catch me beaten off.
That's all you're going to get.
What am I?
I'm not doing anything bad.
I'm beaten off occasionally.
Am I supposed to be ashamed of that?
But for some people it is a shame.
Like Mr. Ryan,
we have photographic evidence of you masturbating.
Like good.
Release it.
Let the Internet see,
release the hounds.
Let them know that I'm just like them.
This is just my dick.
Okay?
It hurts.
I gotta get rid of some stuff.
I've often thought like that would be a great,
a political campaign.
Like the guy who,
who are the woman who became says,
all right,
I'm running for president and let's get this out on the table right here.
All right.
I tripped a lot in college.
I've tried coke,
I've tried heroin,
you know,
like I fucked whores.
Like just get it all out there and see how the country responds to that,
you know.
Well this guy from Toronto is essentially doing that.
Lord
Rob,
what are you pulling up?
Brian?
Rob,
NSA.
Spied on porn part of the plan to discuss this credit radicalizes yeah,
like if you're in a tranny porn that they shouldn't take it seriously.
Sorry.
We're not allowed to say training anymore.
Trying to new transgender and warrant can't say training.
They get upset.
But cabbies you could still call cab drivers cavities.
So let's hang onto that while we can.
Let's hang on to that before the fucking super sensitive police breaks that down
to their cab PR professionals.
They're not cabbies asshole.
You Sis gendered asshole.
I get so much of that stuff,
man.
Of course you do a lot of disenfranchised people out there that want to blow
horn and anybody who will be in earshot.
But it's so frustrating.
I just had this today cause yesterday I released a podcast episode with the
transgender person.
Yeah,
right.
Tell me about
this wonderful person I met.
I met her at a party and I,
at first I didn't realize she was transgender.
What's your dictates like coconut
now that you mentioned it?
Um,
but,
uh,
anyway,
I,
so I released this thing and I get an email today from,
from someone I know who's cool,
who's smart and,
and,
uh,
she's like,
she's a lesbian.
And she's like,
well,
you know,
she was upset because the transgender person dresses like a convention,
a woman and associates with this sort of conventional vision of womanhood.
And so the lesbian is saying she's,
she's supporting a paradigm that makes me feel bad,
that makes me suffer.
That's hilarious.
Like,
Jesus Christ,
the lesbians are fighting with the transgender people.
No wonder nothing ever gets better.
Yeah.
I had the asshole stick together.
I had discussion with his radical feminist woman about,
um,
she w w the discussion originally started talking about transgenders and about
how transgender man is a man to woman is a woman now.
And I'm like,
hmm,
okay,
that's interesting.
I'm like,
I'm more than willing to call them a woman.
I'm more than willing to call them whatever new name they want or whatever they
want to be called.
Sure.
It's not my [inaudible] names to me or fucking ridiculous.
The,
I understand that we need them,
you know,
I can't be like,
ah,
oh yeah,
I know all you about what I have to call you Chris.
Why do I have right.
It's,
it's silly.
And they're coming out of the fucking Bible,
you know,
Saint Christopher's Saint Joseph saying like,
you might as well,
they're random.
A lot of them are random.
You might as well call us,
you know,
by numbers.
What
we were talking about,
which was you got a really weird was we were talking about traditional roles and
um,
and things that women do that discredit other women.
And she was talking about makeup and high heels and I was like,
Whoa,
whoa,
okay.
I know for a fact that if you see a transgender man wearing makeup and high
heels,
you don't have a problem with that at all to you.
And she's like,
you're right.
And I go,
what the fuck is that about?
I go,
if a guy is dressing up like a woman,
if he has a sex change,
becomes a woman.
You're like,
you go girl.
But if a woman wants to wear high heels and let her ass hanging out of a skirt,
you think that there's something wrong with her.
Right?
I'm like,
that's ridiculous.
You're just closed minded.
You're just very rigid in what you expect from other people.
And Yeah,
for sure.
There's some women out there that put on a big show to get sexual attention,
much like a peacock male spreads his feathers.
I mean they're,
they're trying to get attention and it's effective.
I think a lot of the problem that people have with that,
that they don't want to admit is that it bothers them that people are attracted
to that.
It bothers them.
The people are not as attracted to them.
You know,
there's a lot of ugly women who are mad.
It pretty women.
I mean,
it's not fair.
Life is not fair.
And until they come up with some sort of a genetic remedy,
which I believe is within a hundred years,
they're going to be able to take you and turn you into whatever the fuck you
want.
If you want to be a unicorn,
if you want to be the hulk,
you know,
I think they're going to be able to do to your body,
whatever.
I think there's going to be elasticity to our genetics and the design of the
human being will invariably be manipulated.
They're going to change it.
So you're going to be able to look like a beautiful woman if you want to.
And I think when that comes,
man,
it's going to be a weird time because first of all,
I was only going to be available to the elite at first.
There's going to be as glowing perfect specimens that everyone's going to want
to fuck.
No one's gonna want to fuck a regular person with a mole.
You know,
La,
she's got a fucking weird teeth,
you know?
And maybe they'll become exotic or they become exotic.
Most likely not though it most likely to be like cell phones.
Only rich people have met first.
And then within a few decades,
everyone's going to have them because it's going to get cheap.
So I don't wonder how weird it will be though,
because I think we'll be trained for it by our avatars online,
so it will be accustomed to taking these other forms,
you know?
Well,
there's that thing though.
I mean,
this is the thing about competition and the thing about it,
it really does boil down to that people feel like if you're attractive,
you're taking something away from them,
right?
Like I,
I was at a wedding once and there was,
the bride at the wedding was furious because some other woman that one of the
guests had broughten was dressed really sexy.
And she had this band body.
And,
um,
the bride was fucking crying like that.
This was her big day.
And this fucking bitch came in and she's wearing this out.
And it wasn't,
it wasn't anything crazy.
It wasn't like she was wearing fishnets and a bra and it was like,
Kapow,
why get married?
Look at this shit.
This is what you're gonna hear the market fuck face.
And you're set it on for cold mashed potatoes,
you know,
and the woman was attractive as well.
The bride was attractive to was and they were clearly in love and it was,
it should have been a celebration and should have been joy.
And all she could think of was this bitch was upstaging her on her fucking day.
This bitch was,
why the fuck did he bring that bitch?
You know,
why the fuck did she dress that way?
And my wedding apparently like no one knew her.
She was a guest.
You know a friend of the guest.
Fuck.
You know that that competition thing is weird because people feel like you're
taking something from them.
If you have something,
like if you always wanted to play basketball but you're,
you know,
you're five foot eight and like me,
I'm five foot eight and I kind of wish I was as tall as that.
Mao Yang Guy,
whatever the fuck his name is.
He,
what's his name?
The big giant Chinese guy.
Y'All man,
whatever his name is Shaquille O'Neal.
Let's go with shack.
I did fear factor with Shaq and I stood roughly Dick Height to him and it looked
like I was his child with his Dick Taste didn't taste bad,
taste bad.
It tastes like a basketball,
a little rubbery.
It only rubbery side,
very dark.
Um,
you know,
it's like you can't get mad at chuck for being seven feet tall.
Okay.
If we want to play basketball,
you obviously that's not the hand of cards you're dealt my friend.
Right?
And who gives a shit?
Because I mean,
the assumption underlying all of these things is zero sum thinking,
right?
You know that you're familiar with that famine thinking,
right,
exactly.
In fam and thinking came onto the scene after agriculture,
before agriculture hunter,
the way anthropologists describe it is there is an assumption of plentitude in
hunter gatherer societies and in farming societies,
in every society since then,
there's an assumption of scarcity.
It's a completely different way of looking at the world.
You also see it in,
we were talking about a religion.
You see it in agricultural societies.
The gods are angry,
jealous,
temperamental,
perverse.
The gods in hunter gatherer societies on gods are giving,
they're,
they're not even giving there.
They're just like a source of richness.
Yeah,
right.
It's a completely different way of looking at life.
The world,
each other.
It's amazing.
But they never invented shit.
They invented sharper arrows and things along those lines.
There was no cell phones.
If we're all hunter gatherers,
there'd be no internet.
There'd be no podcast right now.
You wouldn't be wearing glasses.
Shit would be weird.
You know,
it would be,
I probably wouldn't need glasses.
You'd be healthier.
I think the glasses is chem trails making your chem trails in my eye,
it's the birth control pills in the water world.
Health Organization works for the new world order.
They,
um,
the,
the people that lived in these hunter gatherer societies though,
they were very happy.
I don't necessarily want to do what they do,
but they were very happy.
Well,
yeah.
I mean,
this is what this book's about.
Sex at dawn,
by the way.
If people are,
what's his fucking books?
Oh yeah.
Actually I was thinking of the other one.
The one I'm working on now,
the new book,
it's called civilized to death and it's about the modern world in conflict with
our evolved nature,
but gets sex at dawn.
Now,
read that before the new book,
the new book,
and to come out about a year after I write it.
You haven't even started,
dare you?
How dare you come in.
I mispronounced colostrum.
Fucking son of a bitch.
You son of a being busy.
I'm busy.
You are.
You are very busy thinking.
Got me into this podcasting shit.
You know,
I didn't even know what a podcast was when I met Dunkin.
Well,
you know,
it's fun.
I love it.
I wouldn't write books if I could do this for a living.
I would just hang out and talk to cool,
interesting people.
It's a more effective way of distributing information to,
I'm amazed how many people listen.
We're getting like 15 20,000 downloads at this point.
That's a lot.
That's really good.
Not Rogan numbers,
but well,
whatever.
I mean,
we started out,
Brian and I,
we got like a hundred the first day we did it.
Yeah,
we got a hundred people watching on Ustream.
You know,
you guys are doing the video from the get go.
Yeah.
We started doing a video.
We're one of the few that doesn't,
we don't do any editing or our shows.
They air warts and all.
They go out there and some people in the,
originally the big knock was that that was very unprofessional that we should
edit it and,
but there's,
but there's a sort of a thrill to it that people know,
like these people appreciate the authenticity.
Yeah.
It's like you're,
you're here.
And also the conversations that we're having,
like this conversation with you,
you can,
you can not just acquire information much more easily than reading,
but it also stimulates your desire to acquire new knowledge in a way that,
I don't
even know if reading does.
It's like you,
you get inspired by a variety.
It's almost like a magazine.
You get inspired by a variety of different ideas and then you can go pursue
those ideas on your own.
But they open up doors and doors to me to not just to the listeners,
they're like,
there's a lot of that.
Just having these conversations,
being able to sit down with a guy like you for three hours and just talk.
I mean how would we do that if we did that?
Normally if we decided to have dinner together we would be,
what are you going to eat?
Oh the the this,
this year is really good.
Be with other people and they'd be having their thing and you know it's,
you're right.
It's extremely efficient.
I mean,
my favorite thing about it is exactly what you said.
It gives me a reason to sit down for a while with someone who otherwise might
not be,
might not make time for me.
Right.
You know,
or half time.
they've got to think about their effectiveness.
Well and also the committing to sitting down for like three hours because we're
calling it a show.
The committing to just sitting here and doing this,
you know,
it's not like checking your phone or I'm going to what's on TV.
It was a,
when does this start?
This is a season of that in and you know,
look at this magazine,
a guy we'll fucking take who took this picture.
You know what I mean?
All that stuff.
Yeah.
It's like life is a distraction.
This is almost like,
yeah,
you got to lock yourself in.
Clink across the table in a weird way.
We would never really sit you.
We'd sit on a couch over there.
I'd be over here.
Which chatting know,
watching the fucking TV.
Probably likely taking most of our time where there'd be music plan or
something.
They'd be something going on where you're,
you're,
you're adding to the distraction of life itself.
There's sun flowers feeding roses,
feeding you a big,
big fast food tray of roses.
Dick tasted like rose pedals.
Wonder what,
what some one of those Weirdo dream expert people would,
how they would decipher that.
Like what would be their,
uh,
Google it.
There's a lot of dream dictionaries.
Oh,
you remember Stanley Kripner he's a dream dream expert.
Yeah.
I don't know what he would say about that.
The man roses without the thorns.
Interesting.
It was just pedals.
Pedals maybe as a beers.
Cause I know the deer.
So did you,
did you bag one?
Yes.
Yeah,
it was at buck season does well,
it's both.
I,
it's kind of a sad story.
Oh,
it was fun season.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I didn't shoot one of those,
but I'm eating rose pedal dream interview.
It's on my Islamic dream.
Oh my God.
My is launching.
Please shut.
Shut this off before we get G.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I had nothing to do with that.
I shot a buck and wounded a doe.
I dropped my rifle because I fell and apparently the scope was off on the rifle
and a,
the the animal got wounded and its leg and we had a followup,
but we couldn't,
we couldn't find it.
We found a blood trail and we followed it for several hours the next day.
Even looking for it,
we couldn't find the deer,
so he got wounded.
It was very,
very depressing,
very sad,
and it was like two extreme opposites.
The,
the buck I shot died instantly.
It was like I got,
I have a large caliber rifle and one of them in the Winchester 300 win mag 300
and the idea behind it was like,
I want to make sure that nothing gets wounded if I wanted it to be as painless,
as quick as possible.
I had my rifle cited the day before.
We went to a range of shot,
a gang around the shot 90 rounds before the day before we left and another 20
the day up.
And I've been practicing a lot.
So my accuracy is excellent.
I was ready to do.
And the idea behind it is very simple.
I mean hunting is very thrilling thing.
What I want to do this year,
and this is in no judgment of anybody who's not doing it,
but I want to be able to know exactly where all my meat comes from and I want it
all to be wild meat.
I think it's better for you.
I think it's an ethical,
much more ethical way than factory farming,
certainly.
And even more than agriculture because that an animal is living it's life
completely free and wild until the moment you pull that trigger.
And,
uh,
so my idea was to get all those ducks in a row,
make sure that I'm shooting an animal,
that I'm definitely going to hit the crosshairs aligned,
lined up on it.
Perfectly.
Fucking scope is off,
scope is off and the animal got hit in the shoulder.
So I went,
um,
I wasn't sure if that was what the case was or if I just miss,
you know,
there's so much adrenaline going on and it's so,
it's so depressing and so sad.
So I went to a range and a,
I went with a um,
uh,
a marksman two and a,
one of the guys we were with and knows how to cite rifles and he's like,
yeah,
this is off Zoloft quite a bit.
It was off by like six inches at a hundred yards,
which is quite a bit.
I mean when you fall,
you know,
I was walking around the slippery hills,
snow everywhere and logs and at these big stupid moon boots I was wearing that
were,
um,
there were insulated boots that were good to like 40 below zero.
But you can't fucking walking them.
I mean,
they're enormous and stiff.
You could,
their ankles don't bend,
so you're like dining exactly.
Like ski boots.
But they keep your feet warm.
But I fell and a huge,
huge depressing moment.
Very,
very sad.
I mean,
it's like the animal will die and it's probably dead already.
And if not,
the coyotes deleted anyway.
It's part of the cycle of life and they're trying to get rid of as many deers
they can up their,
they have a lot of deer and the deer damaging a lot of their,
they're trying to replant forests up there.
Deer eat all the saplings,
the leaves off the oak trees and things along those lines.
It killed people and auto accidents.
They do.
But I was obviously trying not to do that.
Yeah,
I was trying to make sure that it died instantly.
Like the first one,
the buck I shot was dead within seconds.
It was boom vintage.
You have it cleaned.
No,
I did it.
We got it.
It butchered it.
Everything.
Hung it up on a tree.
It took hours.
We did it in a garage.
We skinned it and the whole deal and it took hours to cut it down into porch.
But this is the way,
right way to do it.
The last time we did it,
we send it to butcher.
I have no idea if that was even my dear that I got back.
It tasted delicious.
It was awesome.
But I didn't see it.
I didn't see the whole process.
And to me it's like I was missing a step.
I wonder that when you get the ashes back from someone who's been cremated.
No.
Really?
Oh,
how do I know it's in here?
You know,
stack of newspapers and cocaine and they just shit.
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
it's like they cut it,
they cut.
Your grandmother wouldn't let it go.
You might want to check out that book I mentioned earlier the Omnivore's
dilemma,
Michael Pollan.
Cause the,
the idea of that book was just,
he said,
uh,
I want to make one meal where I know where everything came from.
Yeah.
Well I'm doing that now.
I'm growing vegetables.
I eat broccoli from my garden rose tonight.
I have a pretty serious garden now and it's getting bigger and have chickens
now.
I,
I've,
uh,
14 chickens and I just ordered seven more getting seven.
Would you order them from a chicken factory?
I don't know.
I'll show you.
You order them online,
send them through the U s postal service.
Actually they get next day.
Yeah.
And they're fine.
What did they call the red something reds with dealing with the breed is a gang
of different breeds.
We have a bunch of different types of chickens,
but so you're getting the eggs from there.
I get fresh eggs every day from these chickens.
And then on top of that,
I'm getting vegetables from the garden and I'm trying to go by the end of 2014.
My goal is to be all game meat because I think if you're going to be a meat
eater,
and I've been a meat eater my whole life,
I want to be,
I want to know where the food comes from.
One,
I mean it's great if you can go to a farm that you know the guys taking care of
his cows,
like Doug during the guy who's a farm that I hunted on this weekend,
he has cows and he grabs,
feeds him.
He even gave me some of his meat that he got and I was happy to get that.
You know,
he gave me a couple of steaks.
You know exactly where that came from.
I know exactly what he feeds that.
He knows exactly what that cow's been through.
There's no hormones,
no bullshit.
It's just they're just cows eating grass.
This is what it's supposed to be,
but most of the time you're,
you don't know what that relationship is between the farmer or the butcher or
the,
and you can assume it's bad.
You can set certain real,
certainly if it's factory farm and also the fact that most of the state that
we're getting is fed grain and those animals are not supposed to be in corn and
anybody.
Then the fucking ass he of one of the reasons being is because their body
doesn't process Cornwell.
Right.
So they get all these abscesses and all these issues with their stomachs.
Yeah.
Look,
you know it,
again,
I'm not trying to judge I.
Dot.
I'm not saying go out and do what I'm doing,
but I think knowing what I know about the whole process,
seeing documentaries like food inc and it just,
no,
knowing what I know about,
I don't want to do that.
I I W if I'm going to,
I'm not,
I don't want to be a vegetarian,
but if I had a choice between being a vegetarian and keeping the factory farm
system in place the way it is,
I probably go with being a vegetarian.
I would just eat eggs.
I would just eat eggs and vegetables and you know,
and things along those lines.
But I like meat and I,
I think there's benefits.
I think there's a lot of health benefits.
Me.
I really do.
I find it delicious and I've always said this,
but it's not like those animals are going to live forever and become magic.
I mean they,
they have a short lifespan dear.
If Deere is lucky as fuck,
they hit five years old,
they have to be lucky as fuck to not get eaten by a predator.
He hit by a car shot by a hunter and especially or froze to death,
which is the big issue with you,
especially in non farm lands.
Seeing the place where we were at these dear fat as fuck because they're grazing
on crops.
They're eating Alfalfa,
they're eating on these,
uh,
a lot of these places they actually grow food plots just for deer because deer
hunting first of all,
the opening day is fucking crazy.
We were out there,
it was like five 30 in the morning.
We were out there and an hour before it got light.
And you hear as soon as the sun starts cracking you here.
Yeah.
It's awesome.
It's like you're at a war zone dear day in Pennsylvania as a school holiday.
Yup.
Yup,
I remember seeing people driving home from hunting with like a dead deer
strapped to their pinto.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
You gotta be careful first day of deer season unless you did a dogs and cows get
shot and panthers.
Yeah.
So when you were in like a Oh yeah.
Cammo yeah,
no,
no.
Orange.
Just orange,
orange vests.
We were in a blind sitting there at zero degrees outside the tree.
No,
no,
no.
One time I went up in the tree,
but uh,
it was for a short amount of time.
I only hunted up in a tree for about an hour.
Most of the time was in a blind that was on the ground.
It was,
it's intense because it's nothing,
nothing,
nothing.
You're waiting,
you're freezing.
I mean,
fucking freezing.
It's one,
it's fine if you're walking around,
if you're well insulated and you're walking around,
it's actually kind of pleasant because you feel warm because your clothes are
good.
You're wearing wool and down and all these different things.
But when you just sit down,
nothing fucking keeps you warm.
You have to,
you have to tense your body.
And release and tense your body of these chemical bags.
That's how those help,
they keep your feet warm.
I didn't figure out those until the second day.
They made a big difference and you put them in your gloves,
you hold onto these little bags and they help,
but your face is still fallen off.
You're still sitting there freezing your dick off.
Who knows will not stop running.
But it's quiet,
quiet,
nothing,
nothing.
And then he hears you get a snap and you look up like,
oh shit.
Oh shit,
there's a deer.
Yeah,
it was pretty exciting.
It's very exciting.
We had decide whether or not the deer was big enough for me to shoot because
this guy is trying to raise large deer on his property.
But since they're trying to get rid of as many as possible right now because
they're growing there,
he kind of gave us the green light to shoot a younger deer.
So there was only like two years old.
They liked him to grow like five years.
They get these big crazy antlers.
Right.
But,
um,
you know,
there are big antlers are cool,
but I was doing it for me.
Like that's what I want to do it for.
From now on.
I want to just try to do that every few months and bring back,
you know,
a hundred pounds of meat or what that shoot an elk,
shoot a large animal and just try to live off wild animals.
You know,
my,
my wife's from Africa,
from Mozambique,
I'm leaving
in two days.
We're going to Mozambique,
first time ever for me to be in Africa.
Well,
um,
but uh,
one time we were,
she was raised in a rural,
uh,
her grandmother's house was in a village African village and she spent weekends
out there all the time.
So anyway,
one day we're in Amsterdam,
we're sending in Amsterdam.
It's a beautiful spring day by a canal.
And you know,
these little ducks go by and she's looking at these ducks like really staring at
these ducks and it's got a weird look on her face.
I said,
what are you thinking?
She said,
oh,
I was just thinking how much I'd love to kill that duck.
And rip its guts out and stuff it with garlic and herbs and rosemary living me,
my grandmother,
and like my wife grew up like,
you know,
ringing next of chickens and ducks and geese and you know,
like it's no big deal for her.
You know?
It's like whatever.
That's what you do.
She thinks we're silly.
Americans are ridiculous with our disconnect from where things came from.
Well,
this is this woman that I know who's raising her son to be a Vegan.
She wears a leather jacket.
It's got leather shoes on and she eats meat.
Oh,
but he's got to be kid to be a Vegan kids.
Fucking three.
Yeah.
Somebody needs to call child protective services.
You mean?
I don't know what kind of be 12 they're given the kid and then maybe,
hopefully they're given a B12.
They say a lot of people that they get their beat 12 from actually from insects,
from just the amount of insects that you eat and inadvertently or mixed into
your,
yeah,
it makes any vegetables or on that Burger won't be 12 every day.
A couple of weeks ago.
It's such a great energy boost.
Fuck.
Yeah,
it's great for your body to,
you know,
a trim tech sport.
One of its big ingredients besides the quadriceps mushroom is B12 fantastic for
endurance.
I mean they used to give it to us,
uh,
intro muscularly when we were wrestling,
if,
uh,
like,
someone was feeling tired or down,
they shoot you,
give you a shot at B12 cause a lot of gags were drained.
It's fuck from losing weight and uh,
the pilots use that.
Yeah.
A lot of people,
the best way is the shot.
There's sublingual.
Um,
there's actually a good company that makes a spray that you use sublingually
that works pretty good,
but nothing beats the old injector oni be 12 right into your system.
Yeah,
that's a big issue with vegans not getting B12 because primarily I think it
comes from animals,
but they've,
um,
they actually,
brought this vegan couple two trial for manslaughter or murder or whatever it
was because their child died from malnutrition because the kid wasn't getting
enough.
B 12,
that baby died because they didn't give it the proper vitamins because they
insisted on a vegan diet.
So and not harming animals.
They harm their child,
you know,
life eats life.
And that's a real issue.
Factory farmings eval.
I agree.
I'm with you.
I think,
you know,
it goes along with the same thing that we were talking about earlier with
corporations being that we lost are we lost the script and humanity is not
favored over finances,
over ones and Zeros and humanity should be favored above all else.
It should be
important.
Sessions should be serving us.
Yes.
How did we end up serving the corporate?
They are us
and they are,
because there's,
it's a,
because it's a game because it's a,
you know,
uh,
acumen of game,
you could figure out how to acquire more and there's clear benefits to being,
you know,
the guy who has the giant mansion who gets driven around in a Rolls Royce,
like you know,
there's,
he's got a g five,
he flies his own jet because all those benefits and being that ruthless fuckhead
but you know,
the,
I mean maybe I'm going to sound like one of these vegans here,
but I've known a lot of these guys with the yachts and the mansions and they're
not really happier.
They're not actually happier.
In fact,
a lot of them are much less happy than,
than,
uh,
certainly then people suppose cause when you get that much shit then your life
becomes about your shit.
Yeah.
You got,
you got that much money,
where are you going to invest it?
You know,
people are always trying to get it from you that,
you know,
what does it freedoms another word for nothing left to lose.
Right.
And that's a different kind of freedom.
But I think there's a middle path and I think we make a mistake by assuming that
people are necessarily going to be happier when they get more.
No,
money is one.
There's a broad range of needs that a human has.
And in this society you need a little money cause he need to be able to figure
out how to pay for food and shelter.
And Yeah,
the studies do show that happiness goes up,
uh,
from like seven grand a year to 40 grand a year and then after 40 grand a year
at tapers off.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I was saying once your needs are met,
once your needs are met,
that's not everything after that is not about happiness.
Like I was explaining this to a friend of mine that,
uh,
one of the big things that happened to me when I started doing well and started
making enough money.
I mean,
it was not rich by any stretch of the imagination.
But when I first started doing well as a comedian was that I didn't feel worried
anymore about where my bills are getting paid because every month was like a
fucking terrifying struggle to pay for food and pay for gas.
And it was always like barely under the wire.
I'm paying my rent three days late every month.
It was cause I didn't have it,
you know,
it was just,
it was always like that.
And once that was alleviated,
it was a huge pressure release.
That's what makes you happy when you can go to a restaurant and not worry about
what you order,
you know,
that makes you happy.
Everything after that you get used to,
you get used to a big house just as nice to have a small house you need.
Sometimes it helps.
Smiles is better,
it's cozier,
everybody's connected,
they're all just,
you know,
that's the thing that the greatest predictor of happiness,
once you get past that level of subsistence or you know,
you can take a vacation.
You're not worried about paying your bills and all that.
The greatest predictor of happiness is community,
is sense of community interconnection with other people.
And the,
the,
you know,
shooting ourselves in the foot with the,
the wealth is that one of the things that happens with wealth is that we become
isolated and insulated from other people.
You know?
And what's the difference between comfort and numbness?
You know,
it,
I mean,
I used to travel backpack all over the world and I'd meet somebody and they'd be
like,
hi,
you don't know man,
you gotta you gotta come with me on my private jet.
You know,
we stay at the five star hotels and those people didn't see anything.
Yeah.
You know,
the five star hotels are the same wherever you go,
you know,
like it's different beach out front.
But that's it.
You're not really meeting any of the local people,
whatever.
I mean,
yeah,
whatever.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's,
there's an isolation that comes with money.
And I'm not just talking about wealthy people,
I'm talking on a social level as well.
We're much more,
Americans are much more isolated socially than Indians or Cubans are Brazilians
of lower classes.
You know,
it's,
there's a,
we pay for the money is what I'm saying.
Yeah,
I,
I see that.
I mean,
it makes sense.
And I think that society as a whole gets really weird when you have cities to,
you know,
Jim Norton,
who's a good buddy of mine,
lives in an apartment in New York City and he lives in a building with probably
a thousand people.
I mean,
I don't know how many people live in the building.
I go,
who do you know and that building and he's alert.
He goes,
I don't know anybody.
I say hi to my neighbor every now and then.
I've seen him a couple of times.
He goes,
but I don't know anybody.
So it's even more crazy because unlike a community like your house is next to
your neighbor's house and you see them all in the law,
he say,
hi.
So what do you do?
I'm a printer.
Oh cool.
I write books and you have a little chitchat.
Well,
hey,
if you ever need anything,
I'm next door that doesn't even go on.
And there's a thousand people living in a box stacked on top of each other,
and that is the norm instead of the village.
Like one of the things that I've found really fascinating about your book was a
sex at dawn,
was the way you describe the interconnectedness of these small societies that
the idea of promiscuity that we have today,
that's our idea of it,
is someone going to a bar and picking up a stranger told around stranger and
having sex with someone all willy nilly and crazy.
Like that's not what promiscuity originated as it originated as just having sex
with a bunch of different people that were also in the tribe and it was the
norm.
And you knew them.
Yeah.
Like you've known them for years.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
So we tried to make a big point of that so that people wouldn't get confused by
it,
by our use of the word promiscuity.
Cause as you say,
it means it means now screwing a stranger.
And people don't recognize that in prehistory there really weren't any
strangers.
Yeah.
You know,
so you're talking about that,
that apartment building and how nobody knows each other.
It reminds me of a book I just read recently researching this other one called
paradise built in hell.
And it's,
uh,
it's,
studies of the way people react to disasters,
you know,
and uh,
contemporary mainstream economic theory,
which,
which is sort of based on the idea that we're all selfish and trying,
you know,
self optimizers,
always looking for advantage for ourselves.
That's sort of like built into economic theory would predict that in,
in disasters that people would be even more like that.
You know,
they'd,
they'd be even more protective of resources.
Whereas what actually happens is that in disasters people start helping each
other strangers,
you know,
like those people in that building,
that's when they'll meet each other when there's an earthquake.
Right,
right.
And like,
Holy Shit,
did you feel that?
Or,
you know,
twin towers,
people were so happy after that.
And I think that's also why people enjoy,
I'm not sure enjoys the right word,
but,
um,
you ever heard of Sebastian younger?
Yes.
His book war.
I saw him being interviewed about it.
He's a CNN correspondent,
is that what it is?
Well,
he's,
he's a war correspondent and he was embedded with a marine platoon in the
Korengal valley for like six months in Afghanistan.
And this was like,
they were at the tip of the spear right where they were getting attacked every
day.
Cause they were like in this point in a valley where the Taliban were above them
on the mountains shooting down into their babies.
It was just a horrible thing.
So he was there and uh,
for six months,
I think,
and he was being interviewed about the book,
it's called war.
And he said,
uh,
they said to him,
well,
why did these guys do that?
You know,
I mean,
they don't care about geopolitics.
They're not thinking about oil pipelines and Chinese expansion,
you know,
whatever the,
the guys in the Pentagon or thinking of,
why the hell do they do it?
And his answer was love,
right?
That's what makes these guys go to war,
love for each other.
That they have a sense of community when you're under fire,
right?
Like we talked about it disaster in New York or an earthquake or whatever.
But imagine like every damn day as an earthquake and you're with the same dudes
every day and you're depending on each other constantly.
It creates deep bonds of love that people really miss when they're gone.
And I think those are the bonds our ancestors had.
Yeah.
There's an intensity to life in those circumstances
and an immediacy.
Yeah.
You know,
because any day,
and you were out hunting when you fell,
that gun could have gone off and you could be dead now.
No,
I didn't have bullets in the chamber.
I'm not retired.
Okay,
well it's a,
I mean,
illustrating a point,
a hunter gatherers out with his fucking poison tipped arrows.
If he trips and break your neck or a leopard can kill you or a snake can get you
or you know,
whatever you can.
The immediacy of death is,
I think something,
it's a tonic.
It makes life
immediately.
So you think that maybe that's one of the reasons why people feel so unfulfilled
is that they're not experiencing highs and lows,
that just experiencing a drone,
like a daily drone of traffic and a job that's mundane.
And is that what causes all this depression?
Yeah.
I think so.
In suicides and you know,
all sorts of horrible,
uh,
results of,
this is what I said earlier.
What's the difference between comfort and numbness?
Right.
Comfort is thinking about what we associated with comfort pillows,
blankets,
sleeping bags,
jackets,
cushions,
things that stop us from feeling right.
That's what comfort is a lack of feeling in maybe a lack of negative feeling.
But if you blog negative feeling,
you're also blocking positive feeling antidepressants.
They don't just make you stop being depressed.
They make you stop feeling,
they take the highs and the lows.
They take numbness there making that create numbness.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that I've talked to that have had them and then gotten
off of them,
they'd be like,
it's just like last time.
It's like there was that year meant nothing.
There was like there was missing time that year was just a series of things that
went on that I had no emotional connection to whatsoever.
And that's the antidote for this crazy society that we live in this completely
unnatural and this all the,
all the,
the,
the reward systems that are set up in our bodies from thousands of years of DNA
and learning,
all that stuff is just never appeased.
There's no real thrills.
There's nothing,
you know,
you're,
you're real thrill.
It's like going and buying some illegal drug from someone and just closing your
door and doing it and no one knows,
fuck you.
I'm doing heroin.
You know,
those,
those years.
Yeah.
Well,
and there's a ritual.
I mean a lot of the junkies find the hardest thing about kicking heroin is the
loss of ritual and community.
Like a heroin junkie,
community,
junky community.
You're hanging out with your,
the same people.
You know,
you've got this thing in common,
you've got the ritual,
the burning,
those measuring the,
you know,
syringes,
the whole shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've been interviewing a lot of addiction specialists recently.
Did you have Carl Hart on here?
No.
Oh,
he's cool.
He's a really interesting card.
Carl Hart didK or c because c,
uh,
he's a a neurology professor at Columbia University or h.
I think I sent you an email about him cause he was coming out to do the bill
Maher show like a month ago or something.
And he's got a book out called high price and it's sort of a autobiographical
account of him being born in Miami.
Wrong part of town.
He's a black guy,
you know,
low income.
And uh,
I don't remember if it's his brother or his buddies growing up.
Most of them are in jail.
Uh,
you know,
a lot of,
uh,
grew up in that like inner city drug scene.
Right.
And through good luck and some people who were impressed by him,
he ended up getting a phd and now he's a tenured professor at Columbia,
but he's a dude from that world.
And so he's talking about drugs with a very knowledgeable,
realistic understanding of what they are and what kind of people use them and
why they use them.
You know,
and so his,
he argues that,
you know,
drugs aren't addictive.
What's happening is these people are in this absolutely impossible situation.
And as you say,
they like go get the drugs and get behind the door and say fuck you.
Because it's like the only,
the only escape they've got.
Yeah.
They're unfulfilled.
The,
the idea of the hunter gatherer being a fulfilling life,
like that lifestyle being a fulfilling life,
it's really been appealing to me lately.
One of the reasons why I started this,
uh,
this project of thousand 14 to live off only game meat cause I started seeing
these documentaries like the Warner Herzog documentary on the Taiga Happy
People.
That's a fantastic film.
It's an amazing,
I love everything hurts.
Sogs done.
I've seen all of them,
but that's a wonderful one.
Yeah,
there's a realness to those people.
And then there's also these Alaska shows that I like,
like let a life below zero is one of them was all people that live either below
or right above the arctic circle or a right,
a right below or above the arctic circle.
Some of them 140 miles above the arctic circle.
I mean,
they just fucking freezing your ass off up,
but they're happy.
They have a task.
They do.
It's not my life.
It's not what I want to do.
They're missing a lot of things that I enjoy,
you know?
But there's something about this,
this life that they're living that creates these stable,
happy people.
If you look at reality shows like reality shows drive me fucking crazy,
and I think they should because there's something about putting people on
television for no reason and then following them because they're on television
for no reason.
Like keeping up with the Kardashians.
It's like the kind of ashy hands or just some normal folks.
I'm sure there are no better or no worse than most of our neighbors.
But when you're following these unexceptional people that have nothing to
contribute,
there's no,
they're not doing anything.
They're not releasing songs and not writing books.
They're not contributing to the,
the,
the cultural awareness.
There's nothing going on there,
but yet you follow them anyway because they're being broadcast.
And it becomes something that you're locking too.
But you're dealing with people have an exceptionally low character nonsense
talking.
You listen to things,
they care about the things they say,
like they're essentially children eating the fat of this society,
this,
this oozing,
big,
fat,
sloppy society that just lets them pull up to the trough and feed all them all.
And because of that,
they never are pressured to develop character and true identity and be
exceptional people.
And in the way that these hunter gatherer people are that have watched these
subsistence shows,
you're dealing with these really solid people.
They get up,
it's fucking 20 below zero.
They have to feed their dogs.
They have to pull together these,
uh,
these salmon wheels to gather up all these fish.
So that they could feed their dogs.
If they don't get 200 fish,
200 pounds of fish,
they're going to have to kill one of their fucking dogs because they can't feed
the God damn thing.
So they have to put it out of its misery.
And it's one guy was talking about how he had to kill all his dogs one year.
He had a kill all his fucking dogs.
He couldn't feed them.
I mean,
these are there different kinds of people than someone like,
I hate red shoes.
Why did you give me red shoes?
Oh my God,
my feet are fat.
They're not fast.
Shut up.
She knows my feet are fat and then cut away and she's always telling me my feet
are fat.
And then when I see my feet are fat,
she's like,
no,
they're not.
Well make up your mind bitch.
I mean that kind of nonsense distraction.
When you come home from a day of work and you're all fucked up on Zoloft and
you're just staring at this stupid fucking show,
like what is that?
What is that?
I mean,
is that like some sort of a,
a way that this machine has of getting us to continue to contribute,
continue feeding this machine,
continue buying things and becoming a part of this weird process we have where
all we do is just create new items and blocks of fucking things and stuff.
Your house filled with shit that you buy and everything that you buy just
continues to contribute to this process of constantly creating new shit.
That's it,
man.
Keep running on the wheel.
Instead,
all they care about is that the wheel keeps spinning faster and faster if
possible.
It doesn't matter why.
Right.
I mean I remember listening to this interview with a football coach for years
ago.
It was great,
great moment.
They said,
I don't remember who he was,
but they said,
what's the key to being a great coach?
He said,
well,
you've gotta be smart enough to really understand the game but not smart enough
to see how little it all matters.
I thought,
well that sums up just about everything,
you know,
cause if you think about it,
you realize like this is all bullshit.
You know,
this,
the,
the entire enterprise of Western civilization is not leading to happiness.
It's leading away from happiness,
higher suicide rates,
higher depression rates,
higher lack of,
uh,
of life satisfaction.
Plus we're destroying the fisheries were destroying the fucking planet,
you know,
bit by bit bigger bits all the time.
What's,
what is the point of this,
you know,
and people say,
well,
but you know,
we'll look at the pyramids,
you know,
we created the period,
we use cell phones,
blah,
blah.
But none of that shit matters unless it contributes to human happiness.
And it's demonstrably show that it doesn't.
Therefore,
I mean I,
I hear you,
you say,
well I'd miss this.
I miss that.
I miss a lot of shit too.
There's no doubt about it.
And in the book,
I'm not advocating that we go back to a hunter gatherer societies,
although partial steps like what you're doing are great.
Not because it's going to save the world,
but because title enrich your life and your kids' lives.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
you know,
the whole,
like I'd missed this or that thing is kind of like a non issue because if you
were raised in that society,
then you wouldn't have,
you wouldn't know to miss it.
Right?
So it's not about you or me becoming hunter gatherers,
it's about looking at these two approaches to life,
uh,
independently and saying,
okay,
the people who were born and raised in those traditions,
what's the outcome?
Who's happier,
who's better off,
who has greater life satisfaction,
who has better health?
You know,
look at all these different parameters.
There's a great book.
Um,
uh,
don't sleep.
There are snakes.
It's about the Pina hop people of the Upper Amazon.
This missionary went to live with them and he's the only western who speaks
their language.
It's a very unusual language.
Daniel Everett.
Um,
and uh,
so he went to live with them,
learn the language and,
and eventually they convinced him to adopt their,
a spiritual traditions rather than the other way around.
He abandoned the church that,
I don't remember which church sent him,
but he talks a lot about,
uh,
happiness,
satisfaction.
He says,
some psychologist came and visited the village when he was there.
And these are a hunter gatherer people.
Very little contact with the outside world.
And the psychologist said,
man,
I've never seen anyone happy this much for this Pr.
And he said,
the way you judge it,
as you take videos and you look at how much of the time they're laughing or
smiling,
right?
And he said,
they,
they laugh about everything.
Their house falls down,
they're laughing.
Someone you know,
you,
you're embarrassed,
you laugh.
Like everything is about laughter.
It's very interesting society,
a real look into the mentality of these people.
One of the things that's really striking about them is that they don't,
you know,
we're talking about focus,
right?
They don't have a sense of future or past that extends beyond,
uh,
pass beyond the generation of the grandfathers.
So when the missionary showed up and started talking about Jesus,
they'd be like,
okay,
did you know
guy?
And he'd say,
no,
no.
This was long time ago.
Did your grandfather know him?
No,
no,
this was before my grandfather and have conversation.
We're done.
They're done.
That's like,
then it's meaningless.
Wow.
You know,
there's no connection between you and this store.
There's,
I don't want to hear about this.
Fuck it.
They just walk away.
That's Intel.
Absolutely not interested.
Yeah.
I mean it doesn't,
you know,
obviously it's nice to have history.
We have a lot of it and you can learn a lot from reading about amazing shit that
happened a long time ago.
This documentable.
But that's pretty funny.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we would,
the problem we have is it's so deeply ingrained in our idea and our idea of
culture so deeply ingrained that when you're talking about happiness,
that happiness without money,
without success,
it's like,
come on,
you know,
like we don't buy it.
Like if you're talking about like a guy who's got a,
you know,
half a million dollar house and you know,
he drives a Cadillac and works all day.
And I'm like,
well listen,
you know,
we've,
we've decided to start a commune and we're real,
we're going to be really happy.
We're going to grow her own food.
What are you gonna do for money?
We're not going to have any money.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Look at this house.
I God,
look at this car.
Come on.
I need to pay for gas.
It costs a lot of money to just the electric bills,
$500 a month.
You know,
people get this idea in their head that you're what?
This thing that you're doing,
this part of this role that you're playing in this society is the only way to be
happy.
It's inevitable.
Yeah.
To step outside of that and have like a,
a radical restructuring of what you do.
It's really impossible.
You know why?
Because you're always going to have to pay taxes on that fucking house.
You're always going to have to be,
even if you buy your house,
if you own your land,
you don't,
sorry.
Every year you have to be fucking property tax period.
In Spain,
it doesn't work that way and be marked down.
Yeah.
You pay the tax up front when you buy it and then you're done.
That's it.
It's yours.
Unless you're talking about gigantic chunks of land.
Like if someone's got a goddamn huge cattle ranch,
it's got 3000 acres and that it's obvious like they're using them a lot of
resources,
a lot of waters,
a lot of,
he should probably pay some sort of a tax on that.
But if you're just a guy and he's got $150,000 $200,000 house and you worked
your whole life to earn that house and you,
you bought it and paid for it,
you should be fucking done just like you're done with your car.
Or you don't have to keep paying your fucking car over a year.
You'd have to like,
what's your car worth this year?
Well,
you owe us 10% of that boy.
Like I paid it already.
Like we talking about it paid sales tax.
You guys got to cut when I bought the fucking thing.
Like why do you keep getting a cut every year?
Like what does this property text nonsense?
It's stupid.
It's ridiculous and it keeps you on the tit.
It keeps you on the tit.
You can never just go off the grid.
Right.
One of the shows that I watch is this show called mountain men and there's a guy
named Eustace Conway and he lives in North Carolina and this guy is totally off
the tit.
All right,
all he does his little off and he's got a generator that uses the river water.
The river water spins this wheel that creates electricity and that's how he
powers his band saws.
He cuts his own wood chops.
He has like a couple thousand acres out there and he lives off deer meat that he
shoots.
It was about chickens that he raises and he's off the land,
grows his own Kale,
the whole deal.
But his big dilemma paying his fucking property tax every month.
So every year you know it,
he's got to figure out how to sell things.
He's got to chop wood and sell woods.
You gotta do all these different things when really he paid for all that shit,
which is leave that guy alone.
He's not hurting anybody by living off the land that he paid for it,
like get the fuck off his back.
But they are always going to do that.
They're always going to keep you tied in if they can,
if they can figure out a way to keep sucking money out of you.
And it's essentially a justification for the incompetent system.
The current system is so fucking filled with just,
just gross misspending and misappropriation and mismanagement of funds,
just so gross and sloppy and bureaucratic and they just,
they need to be to everybody to be on the tit in order to feed that stupid
inefficient machine.
You're here,
man,
here,
when you were talking about Alaska,
you know,
and getting off the grid and all that,
uh,
you know,
I had a transformative experience that first time I went to Alaska I,
I was in college in New York,
I was studying literature and one of my teachers was a visiting professor that I
had got to be friends with,
was the youngest person to ever be a professor at Oxford.
He's like a real big shot at Oxford.
I mean since 1261 or something,
this guy's the youngest person to ever be a professor.
Then how old was he?
21 when he was a full day focus on,
yeah.
Wow.
Anyway,
he's very well known guy.
Indira Gandhi was his godmother.
He's written a bunch of books and all this and he was a friend of mine and he
was,
uh,
I was in my,
I was skipping my junior year of college and the one,
I had one more year of undergraduate and then I was going to go to Oxford for my
phd,
thanks to this guy and his connections and I was going to like study literature
that I'd do a phd and by the time I was 30 be teaching somewhere,
hopefully have tenure and be all set for life and all that.
So I skipped my junior year because I found a loophole in the student handbook
where I could like scam through I,
which I've done like every school I've ever been in,
every job I've ever had,
I find some scam.
Right.
So I,
I a scam my way out of junior year and I said I'm going to go to Alaska because
I want to see the frontier.
So I hitchhiked from New York to Alaska,
had all these freaky adventures as you can imagine.
Right.
Went to prison,
got shot at,
you know,
all this crazy shit happen.
And I met people along the way who picked me up,
especially like in the Yukon and in Alaska who were so fucking kind.
Yeah.
So competent and they'd take me home.
I'd say,
you know,
they feed me,
introduced me to the wife,
the kids that you know,
that or women who'd stopped and picked me up.
Just trusting like,
Hey,
whatever,
you know,
really self sufficient people.
They built their own houses,
they had healthy relationships,
they knew how to fix their own cars.
They were really self sufficient.
None of them knew anything about the fancy schmancy literature and philosophy
that I was studying.
Right?
Like I had,
you know,
the collected poems of Dh Lawrence and my backpack and they'd never heard any of
this shit.
Right.
But when I compared them to my professor friends back at school and it was like,
wait a minute,
these people don't know any of this,
you know,
the elite knowledge.
But they're really happy people and they're healthy people and they have good
families and they're decent and they're kind and they're generous to me.
And then I imagine one of them,
you know,
stumbles into Princeton,
New Jersey or your,
where I was going to school in upstate New York and my professor friends,
you know,
come upon them,
they'd,
they'd laugh at them,
they wouldn't help them,
they wouldn't be kind to them.
They would.
And my professor friends like had to call a fucking electrician to change a
light bulb.
Right?
So it's like,
well,
why wait a minute?
What a,
what do I want to do in this life?
Where am I going?
So that's what I just said.
All right,
fuck it.
No Grad school.
And I wrote to the guy like,
just,
sorry,
not going to printer Oxford.
Not not going to do any of this till I'm 30 I'm not going to make a commitment
to anything.
No job,
no woman,
no Grad School,
no med school,
nothing.
I'm just going to float around the world and have adventures.
Wow.
That's fucking cool story.
I love that idea.
That's a,
that's really cool.
I found out a,
I didn't go to the Yukon but I went to anchorage
recently with,
with Ari.
Right.
You guys went fishing.
We went fishing.
We were the Kenai peninsula.
Mm.
South of Anchorage.
Um,
quite honestly,
I don't remember.
I don't remember what river we're on.
I remember we had a great time.
Yeah.
Uh,
we caught some salmon and we,
we did a show up there,
but I felt that way as well about the people that there's a self sufficiency to
a lot of the folks that live up there that eat mean.
Even in Anchorage,
which is a city,
you know,
it's a real city.
They have,
you know,
hotels and gas stations and the whole deal movie theater went to the movies
there.
It was 10 o'clock at night.
It was out.
Yes.
It's very weird.
It's very weird bars with no windows.
Yeah.
He can't can have windows because people are in their drink.
And you don't want to see your fucking son come your eye and let you know what a
loser you are.
Thanks.
Yeah.
And people will make better decisions and there was a light on them.
We don't want that.
So
do they still have like handgun permits where you have to leave your gun at the
door when you go into the
some places like a gun check?
Yeah.
You have to check your guns when you come in because everybody's got guns.
Get Shit faced.
They need to pick up your gun on your way out.
Yeah.
That's the best time to get it.
After you've gotten enough far arc.
Exactly.
You find people there.
They were very kind and very cool and very competent as you were saying.
And they're just,
there are people that are also dealing with nature and a,
and I'll weigh different level.
Yeah.
They're dealing with weather,
you know,
real weather and we don't have to do that.
We,
especially in California,
which is the most ridiculous and retarded state in the country as far as the way
people behave on the norm.
Don't get me wrong.
I love it here.
And there's a lot of cool people here and you know,
all my best friends are here,
but the reality of California is that we don't have to deal with weather at all.
The worst thing we have to do is press a button.
Oh my God,
it's hot.
You press a button,
it's not hot anymore.
I mean it's really,
as long as the power stays on really,
not that fucking hard to deal.
But if you living in Alaska,
you have to take precautions every year.
You have to keep a candle in the back of your car.
You have to keep matches.
You have to keep blankets with you at all times because your car could break
down.
You can be at the side of the road,
no one could be on the road and that candle,
it might keep you alive.
You Are the light that candle in your car with all the doors shut,
and that's the only way you're going to stay warm and stay alive.
Like there's a,
there's a lot of that kind of thinking going on there.
And then when someone sees you pulled over to the side of the road,
they're not like,
oh,
who's this creepy fuck you know,
in um,
the Sherman oaks that's pulled over to the side of the road with his hazards on,
I'm not stop them to this guy.
They're like,
Oh,
who is this person,
this kindred soul out here in the middle of the woods that got fucked and this
could be me.
Yay.
Come on in exam.
Do you guys have cell phone service?
No.
If we drive five more miles,
we get cell phone service,
hop in the car.
I'll take you to where we can call somebody.
Yeah,
there's not,
but you're right.
Your pre press,
her friends to not pick them up would be right where they live.
That's the crazy thing about it.
It's like you're right that the professor was probably wouldn't pick up someone
who has broken down the side of the road,
but they're right too and not doing that.
If you live in a city because you never know what the fuck you're going to get.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You got it.
You got to participate in the world you're born into,
whether you agree with it or not.
Yeah.
You know,
you're,
sorry to interrupt you with that.
What you said about California,
that also ties to the origins of civilization.
Actually in a funny way there,
one of the leading theories for why Europe became more advanced use in quotes,
right.
Um,
is because people had to,
had to think twice there people they had winter.
So when you build a house,
it has to be better engineer.
The best engineers,
you know,
the best cars,
German,
you know,
they're not Italian because in,
in architecture
and all this stuff you see in Europe,
the,
the Mediterranean countries are sloppy,
right?
The,
the,
the houses aren't insulated.
They're not the,
the fittings aren't right.
You know,
people like show up late.
The whole mentality is kind of laissez faire,
whatever.
Well,
that's the,
whether it's a reflection of the,
whether it's a reflection of the fact that they're not battling weather for
their lives.
So there is a competence and a sort of carefulness and uh,
you know,
checklist.
If you're a pilot,
you use a checklist because if you don't,
your deer a dead pilot,
you know,
it's like that in northern climates as well.
It develops a certain kind of approach to life that's much more competent.
And then on the other hand,
you've got places like Brazil where the weather's fantastic and the people are
like laughing and they were on the beach.
They're smiling and very friendly and very warm.
And that's also because they don't have to,
they don't have to deal with any bullshit.
They're all wearing flip flops.
I mean,
nobody has to worry about nothing.
It's no matter what the time of the year is,
it never gets cold.
And now there's people in Rio that a surf in 24 hours a day,
seven days a week,
they can do whatever they want.
There's no sharks down there either.
We think that recently someone got bit by a shark in Brazil was like a really,
really rare situation.
Yeah.
So they're like surfing perfect water.
It's like bath water.
Beautiful waves.
Ah,
AH,
hot.
Hi.
Everything's great.
I know you like a Verna Hertz.
Ugh.
You ever see a documentary called bus one oh seven it was called,
it's,
it's not Verner Herzog,
but it's a,
it's a documentary that will blow your fucking mind.
I know you're into grizzly man too.
I really love it.
Yeah.
Oh,
the music in grizzly man.
no,
no.
I'm thinking of into the wild.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Anyway,
uh,
this,
this film,
is it bus one oh seven?
And is that coming up?
It's bus one something.
I don't remember which number,
but it's a Brazilian documentary and it's available with subtitles.
It's about this guy who tries to hijack a bus.
And his idea is just to like,
uh,
grab some money and jump off the bus.
But there's some cops going by and they stop and the bus gets surrounded and
then suddenly it's like,
well,
it's not at all what he intended.
He didn't intend to be on this bus with 30 people holding them all hostage.
But now he's there and then the TV cameras show up and their helicopters and
their TV crews all around.
And it turns into this like national day where everyone in Brazil is watching
this dude on the bus live coverage.
Wow.
You know,
it's like the Oj,
you know,
that's one 74,
one 74 highly recommended documentary,
uh,
for insights into Brazilian life and just something you,
you,
you'll never see.
It's like grizzly man in the sense that there's a lot of,
uh,
actual footage used in the documentary.
So you get the interviews and stuff,
but then you've got the,
the,
the footage that the TV crews were,
were taking at the time.
There he is.
Yeah.
It's a very intense,
wow.
That's
fucked.
Okay.
I'll check that out.
Yeah.
Um,
I think that a certain amount of nature having to deal with a certain amount of
adversity develops character.
It's one of the issues that I have with modern life as far as like,
people just getting a nice,
safe job is that you're,
you're,
you don't really have to deal with too much.
Adversity is not,
there's not a lot of risk involved and a lot of fear and parents like that for
their children.
It's like take a safe job,
Johnny,
you know,
they get the,
you get in the union and you've got a good,
good Korea,
they have good government job.
But when you do that,
when you reduce those risks,
you also reduce the excitement of life.
You take away some of the thrill of life.
My whole life I've been a thrilled junkie,
you know,
and in more ways than one I've avoided the,
the,
the fear,
like the drugs and the things that can really fuck up your life.
I've avoided all those cause I've,
I've seen them happen before,
but if I didn't avoid them,
I for sure what it got hooked on something,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a crazy person.
You have an addictive personality.
Yeah,
for sure.
100%.
Yeah.
But I funnel it into being addicted to positive things,
right?
Like I get addicted to martial arts.
I get addicted to standup comedy or get addicted to,
you know,
things that I like,
but those,
um,
they're thrills.
That's what I'm addicted to.
I'm addicted to like martial arts.
One of the things about it that was so exciting is regular life became so much
more manageable when four or five days a week I was fighting for my life.
It's like it was a reality of,
of a mad scramble with some crazy brown belt has got a nasty guard and you guys
are doing battle and he's trying to choke the blood out of your neck,
you know?
And because of that,
everything else I would do would be so much less threatening and so much more in
context.
It would,
it would give it a context and it would give it a person.
And it also cleanses the mind to be terrified.
Yes.
I mean,
I wrote a motorcycle for seven years in Spain.
I had a BMW,
Spain.
I wrote it every day.
Every night.
That's so crazy.
Uh,
yeah.
I used it for work.
How many accidents?
Uh,
you know what?
A lot of near misses,
uh,
some crazy near misses,
but I never dropped it.
Whoa.
That's amazing.
I've dropped other motorcycles.
I almost died on a motorcycle in a while.
I almost died on that one.
But that's another story.
But the first time I almost,
I took a bike,
a trail bike,
I laid it down and slid under a Barb wire fence.
Oh my God,
I was like 14 oh my God.
They kinda just shredded you.
And then the time,
the next time I was in Thailand,
I was in Chiang Mai,
Thailand and I rented this a Suzuki one 85 like a small light bike and I did
like a six day trip around the Golden Triangle and North West Thailand,
which borders Burma in Laos and it's where like 80% of the heroin in the world
comes from.
That's also where I tried heroin,
which was a weird time.
But
did you try an injection or did you try it?
I smoked it.
Smoked.
I met these two British guys.
God is such a weird thing that I was,
and I remember exactly when it was because I got up early like seven o'clock in
the morning to watch Mike Tyson fight James Bone crusher Smith.
Oh,
I remember that.
So,
and it was being shown in this little bar cafe in Chiang Mai near where I was
staying.
And I got up early because I wanted to see it.
And these two British dudes and me,
we're the only ones there.
So I got to,
and they were junkies and they were like super high class dudes.
Like one of them,
his uncle was in parliament and the other was the son of a very famous writer
whose book I had read,
actually,
I won't say his name,
but a very well known.
He won the booker prize and big deal.
Anyway,
these,
these two were junkies and they were in,
so the one dude was in Thailand ostensively to be,
uh,
an actor in the taping of good morning,
the film you have.
Good Morning Vietnam,
the Robin Williams film that they were taping at the time in Bangkok.
That was the story he gave his parents bullshit.
He was just getting high all the time.
And then his friend was like,
oh,
I got to go save him.
And then,
so he came and now he's getting high.
And I met the two of them with this Mike Tyson fight.
And so,
and I had always,
you know,
my,
my thing about drugs is I'm not,
I don't have an addictive personality.
I'm too lazy to be addictive on it.
It's really,
so I do things,
I get the thrill out of it and I try to be careful about it.
And you know,
I like to do things in the place with that.
It comes from,
right.
I've done Iowa skin,
Brazil and piety in Mexico.
And so I'm in northern Thailand in Chiang Mai.
It's going to be the cleanest,
best quality heroin ever.
And I meet these two guys and they're into it and they've got all the contacts
and all that.
And uh,
so they,
we got to be friends and uh,
you know,
they invited me to,
to get high and I was like,
okay,
look,
I've never done this before.
They,
Donna,
will,
we got you a no worries.
So we're sitting in their room and we did the chase the dragon,
you know where you put the heroin on tin foil and you cause the flame can't
touch the heroin.
It's like they don't ruin it.
Yeah.
I can't go to prison for saying this.
Right.
In talking about this,
this is all hearsay,
but you know what non Americans,
if you admit that you have ever used illegal drugs,
they can,
they stamp your passport.
You're never allowed in the country.
I know of two friends that happen to,
so if you're in another country and you start talking about using drugs,
like on another podcast,
they can,
I don't know,
I don't know about podcasts,
but what happened with his friend?
She was coming back from Amsterdam.
She was a judge in the cannabis cup competition and she lives in Vancouver.
And the plane,
she changed planes in Seattle and they took her and said,
so where are you doing in Amsterdam?
And she told them and they said,
so who have you smoked marijuana?
She said,
yeah,
and they stamped password.
She's never landed in the u s again.
Wow.
Because she smoked marijuana in Amsterdam.
And another guy I know is a psychiatrist,
a Canadian psychiatrist who had worked with LSD psychotherapy and they stopped
him at the drive through border,
you know,
at Vancouver and interviewed them.
They've the Wiki PDM and,
and I'm like,
Oh,
you did a research with Lsd,
have you ever used LSD?
And he said,
yeah,
stamp.
Wow.
He's never allowed in the country.
That's crazy.
That's all.
Is that only America as far as I know,
Canada's rough if you get them drunk driving in America,
good luck in,
in Canada.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
A lot of,
um,
a lot of fighters have issues getting into Canada for fights.
A lot of comedians have issues.
A lot of comedians have had issues getting into the Montreal comedy festival,
which was one of the big events for standup comedian because of drunk driving.
Yes.
Cause a drunk driving conviction.
I need domestic violence or anything like that.
Yeah.
Eddie Bravo had,
um,
an arrest for having a gun on him legally.
Okay.
He was a working for a check cashing place and he used to have to carry large
sums of cash in his car to another location.
And so he would leave with a check cash company and he had a registered
concealed carry permit for a gun.
And so,
uh,
he got pulled over for something and he had to tell the,
the cop officer,
uh,
I worked for checkouts and company.
I have a legal registered hand gun in my car right now.
It's loaded.
And then they go,
okay,
hold on a second,
we're going to put you in handcuffs and we're going to run this.
So they run it.
They go,
okay.
Checks out.
They let them go because it was not even supposed to be on his record because it
was all legal.
It doesn't matter.
Every time he goes to Canada,
they sit him down.
Tell us about this.
You have a gone on inside you right now.
You take a gun,
you should to go for the border.
No,
no,
no.
I was,
I was working for a company.
I was allowed to have this,
like it cut,
he's got an extra hour every time he goes into Canada.
It happened to quickly and immigration going into Canada.
What'd you get a,
what was your issue?
They asked me if I'd ever been convicted of a crime and I said no,
and I go sit down and then they call me over and they said,
uh,
the guys like,
um,
you said you'd never been convicted of a crime,
correct?
I said,
yeah.
He said,
is there anything you'd like to say about Fairbanks Alaska in 1983?
And I was like,
uh,
yeah,
I got busted in Fairbank's,
you know,
a for eating a snickers bar in the fucking grocery store and not paying for it.
And,
but I did two or three days.
It was Memorial Day weekend.
I did three,
four nights in the prison.
And then the guy said,
you know,
20 hours of community service and this will disappear from your record and get
if you don't get arrested in a year.
So I always say no because I wasn't convicted of anything.
And they said it would be taken for my record.
And the guy's like,
nope.
The fact that you were not Alaskan so you're from out of state meant they
couldn't strike it from your record.
So,
and it's on your FBI record,
which is we get in Canada.
So he was knicker thief.
Yeah,
I'm a sneaker thief,
so he's a cool guy.
I did four days in a fit in a federal medium security prison with no underwear
for a snickers.
For snickers.
What do you mean with no underwear?
Were you wearing anything or just naked?
I was a wearing shorts.
Why didn't you have pants at the grocery store you tell us about because it
makes it more harrowing.
Come on man.
I was,
I was 19 years old.
That,
yeah.
Will you liked very twink ish.
I was twinkie.
I was very twinkie.
Yeah,
you were worried it was all going to go down.
I would've been worried if I were wearing,
you know what?
Anything,
you know,
survival suit.
But yeah.
Is that even,
isn't that under the amount of money that they could even bust you for
something?
Maybe not.
In the 80s Reagan was in president,
they were trying to fucking be tough on crime,
just say no.
Yeah.
And also I had a,
I mean what happened was we got in from this 10 day hitch with these two guys
I'd met on the ferry coming up the inside passage and we had this long hitch
through the Yukon territory,
all this crazy shit.
And the,
and we get to Fairbanks.
So the first place we go is the laundromat because we stank,
right?
We didn't have that special soap,
your defense defense.
So,
and a,
so we went to the laundromat,
we put everything possible in the washer.
So all three of us were wearing shorts with no underwear,
boots with no socks and a jacket with no shirt.
And then one of the guys was like,
oh,
he wanted to go to the grocery store because there was a PE fund.
And he was going to call his girlfriend to let her know that he'd arrived on
time.
And I was like,
fuck it.
I'll go over with you and the other guy's gonna stay with the bags or backpacks
and all that shit.
You know,
watch the clothes.
So I went with him.
Somebody who was on the phone,
we start pushing a cart around.
We were like,
you know,
Soviet immigrants,
like,
oh so many kinds of,
you know,
food here because we'd been living in the woods eating nuts and chocolate and
LSD for the last 10 days.
And so he,
he opened a,
a thing of Keifer as first time I'd ever heard of Keifer,
which is like liquid yogurt and drank that great for your body.
Acidophilus.
And I,
uh,
I,
for some reason,
eight a snickers bar,
even though I'd been eating chocolate and not much imagination there.
And then we,
he used the phone,
we ditch the cart and we laughed.
And so there's some security guy had seen us and turned into a thing.
This cop showed up and I had a knife in my boot and some grass in my pocket,
both of which were legal at the time in Alaska,
but it was enough to make this cop not like me at all.
And he was like this,
you know,
he Napoleonic comp kind of situation and he didn't like smart ass college kids
from outside coming into Alaska in the summer snickers bar fucking around
fucking around with Kiefer.
So he took us,
he handcuffed us and took us to prison.
Fairbank's correctional center.
Did you not have the money for the snickers bar?
Yeah,
we have plenty of money.
He just didn't want to pay for it.
But it was like,
well you tell it to the magistrate.
Oh you mean for that now that was just like,
I don't know what the fuck you're just young and dumb and you know,
and maybe there was a line or something.
I don't remember.
We pretended we were shopping so we put like dog food and Shit in the carts,
you know,
and we ate our stuff and put the,
the package,
like we were going to pay for it when we checked out.
Right,
right,
right.
So I don't know what we were just being dumb,
but uh,
yeah.
So we ended up being taken to this prison and I had a pipe to yeah cause I
remember when we were,
did the intake,
the guy that like the prison dude who booked us and you know did the whole
intake thing,
I was joking with him,
I was like yeah,
I'm not going to get that pipe and grasp back Emma.
And he was like,
I don't think so man.
I was like,
well you know it wouldn't bother me if it just disappeared and was never even
registered because grass is hard to come by in Alaska wasn't then.
And so we sort of had a little understanding like I'm cool,
you're cool.
Cause he was like,
what the fuck you have snickers bar,
why would this guy,
what's wrong with that cop?
Did you like hit him or something?
And I'm like,
no it,
you know,
he just had a hair up his ass.
So this guy was cool.
He saved us because what he did is he said,
look,
I'm not going to put you guys in with the general population.
You're going to sleep in the gym at night.
Hope you got some cots,
you sleep in the gym,
you never let the other one out of your sight the whole time you're here,
you go to the bathroom together,
you go to the showers together,
you watch each other's back and you'll get through it all right.
And we did,
it was wild and this was like 83,
I guess.
And um,
so the,
there's a lot of money in Alaska right from all the oil.
So the prison was plush.
It was like every meal was all you can eat,
salad bar,
whole wheat rolls,
white roles.
Wednesday was prime rib day where the cops could pay a buck to eat with the
prisoners.
But the catch was you only had 20 minutes each meal.
So I remember like one day we're sitting there at this table,
we're in like 19,
maybe 20,
something like that.
We're sitting at this table and the guy across the table looked like Charles
Bronson.
You remember him,
the stash and the tats and all that.
And we were just like,
this dude was shoveling it in and he looks up at one point he says,
this is the best fucking prison I've ever been in.
Yikes.
And you've got a laundry list of prisons that don't,
don't meet that criteria at the standard.
Yeah,
he,
his story was,
he founded dude with his wife and he beat him with a lead pipe and he didn't
know if he was dead,
but as soon as it happened,
he got in his car.
He was from like New Mexico or Arizona.
He got his car and drove to Alaska because he knew he'd get picked up and he
wanted to get picked up in Alaska because he'd heard the prisons were much
better.
That's hilarious.
So he might've beat a guy to death and said,
the way to deal with this is to go to a place that I was awesome prisons.
And that place just happens to be on the exact opposite of the continent fucking
far as shit.
It's a long drive to drive to Alaska.
Can you actually drive straight to Alaska?
The Alcan Highway?
Whoa.
What is that like?
It's bumpy or at least it was shitty.
Yeah.
Cause you know every winter it gets all torn up.
And how many lanes is it most of?
It's two lanes.
One Lane on each side so you can get stuck behind some asshole that wants to go
40 miles an hour.
Well there's a lot of passing.
I mean it's,
it's a lot of,
it's just flat and cause like the Yukon's Tundra.
Right.
It's just like being,
you know,
it's just flat scrub plants.
I can't imagine someone driving all the way the fuck to Alaska.
That just seems insane.
I just drove to La from Vancouver by way of Utah that tag 10 days.
But I mean we stopped and went hiking in Utah.
Trip out of it.
Yeah.
How many hours was it actual driving?
I don't,
I dunno.
It was about 6,000 kilometers I think.
Which is what,
4,000 miles?
Something like that.
3,800 something like that.
Yeah,
I think it's 2.2 per,
yeah.
Yeah.
2.2 kilometers per mile.
Something along those lines.
A hundred kilometers of 60 miles.
So it is something that I want to like 60 miles an hour is 100 kilometers.
60 to 62 mile now.
Yeah,
that's a,
Utah was great.
Yeah,
Utah is amazing.
It's so beautiful,
man.
Moab.
Oh
yeah.
We were in Moab and then I been wanting to go to Moab since the early eighties
because I'd read this book called the Desert Solitaire by Edward Abbey ever at
that point.
It's a great book.
Essays about the desert.
He's like,
uh,
Edward Abbey was like a,
a red neck philosopher,
hippie.
I mean he just integrated these worldly.
He was like,
uh,
like who's the singer?
Willie Nelson.
He's like a Willy Nelson kind of author,
you know,
like country guys from Pennsylvania originally.
But he moved out west in the 60s and got a job as a fire lookout in arches
national monument or one of those parks or maybe just canyon lands right there.
And I spent the summer by himself in this house,
you know,
just with this incredible view looking for lightening strikes and a,
and he wrote about,
he wrote essays and the book became this cult word of mouth classic.
It's probably sold a million copies by now.
Wow.
It's a great book.
So I'd want it to go there since I read that book in the early eighties.
And,
uh,
this was the first chance that guide,
man,
it's amazing.
I have a good buddy who was a living outside of salt lake for a while and then
he had to move to Arizona and he fucking hates it.
He had to move there for work,
but he just ranted and raved about how great Utah was.
And then I went up there this winter to go skiing for the first time.
I suck at skiing.
That's beside the point.
It's so beautiful up there.
So God damn gorgeous to me.
Rolling Hills.
And then we were there this summer.
Um,
we went there the winter to ski and then I was there this summer,
um,
filming the TV show,
the sci fi show,
one of the things we did was in Utah and everything was fucking green and
gorgeous.
And you just get to see what it looks like when it's not covered in snow.
And it's like,
oh my God,
this is paradise.
The red
rock country.
Yeah.
Down in,
down in,
you know,
the
arches.
Yeah.
It's just the,
it's just phenomenally beautiful.
This sell some sweet spots in this country.
Yeah.
I mean,
the thing for me,
I,
I shit on America a lot.
Anyone who follows my Twitter feed sees me bitching about America constantly.
But the thing America's got that Europe doesn't have is just incredible natural
beauty and large scale,
you know,
it's not some little part,
like the Grand Canyon,
Yosemite.
Yeah.
I mean,
but there are just massive chunks of amazing.
All these parks around Moab are amazing.
Alaska.
The whole fucking state is just an off the charts man.
Yeah.
Really Nice.
We were in,
um,
Seattle for uh,
the Scifi show and Dunkin and I went to Mount Rainier and we drove off.
By the way,
it's only like 50 miles outside of Seattle and it's,
you're in the mountains from Seattle.
It's like,
it's like a cloud.
It's massive,
massive of gorgeous.
And just,
it sort of highlights that city.
I think it's one of the reasons why that city is so cool.
It's got the ocean there to keep you humble and then it's got this massive
mountain.
It's like,
listen bitch,
you ain't shit relax.
But when we drove up there,
I mean Dunkin,
I could just could not stop like rolling down the window and just sticking our
heads out and go,
God,
is this real?
It's so gorgeous.
Just deep rich green with like low clouds everywhere because you know,
you're pretty high altitude up there in the mountains and it's just the fog and
the clouds and the trees and it's just so alive in the air.
You feel like you could eat it.
It's about when you were watching and we're squashing.
Yes.
It's a technical term.
Glad you used that.
It's like I follow your,
your movements.
Yeah.
People who are not squatch enthusiasts don't,
you know,
they don't know the right terms.
They might say you're out big footing.
That's not correct.
We were squatch big footing.
That's snowshoeing.
Yeah.
Wasting your time.
Hey,
easy.
Well one of the things that the guy said that uh,
we went squashing with this guy,
John,
Steve,
very,
very cool guy there.
The both guys we went with were very,
very nice guys.
Took cool actually in the show.
Yeah.
Very,
very cool.
Pretty chill.
Yeah.
And well one of the things that they said was like,
look man,
even if there's no big foot,
we're still out here camping.
Yeah.
We're,
we're having a good time.
It's beautiful woods that we're in.
And like,
I liked that,
that attitude.
Well that's what people say about fishing and hunting as well.
Although it sounds like your,
your trip wasn't as enjoyable sitting in a freezer,
but it was enjoyable still.
I liked it a lot.
I like suffering a little bit.
I think it's important to get the fuck out in the woods,
you know,
and hang out with your buddies and you know,
have a good time.
And the guy owned the land.
His name is Doug.
Um,
he took me to this one spot.
We win a hunting and I went up in the tree stand and he,
he likes to do a lot of his hunting,
walking around.
And so he said,
let's,
let's split up for a little bit.
I'll go this way.
You sit in the tree stand and maybe if me walking around,
sometimes it'll scare a deer towards you.
Um,
and uh,
when I was sitting there,
it was just me alone for like an hour
and there wasn't a single sound.
Every now and then I'd hear like a little squirrel chip,
but there's no TV cameras this time we had basically finished filming what we
need to film for the show.
So it's just me sitting up there in the stand,
like looking around,
waiting for a deer show up,
but just soaking in the beauty of the woods and it's the driftless area of
Wisconsin,
which means is the area of the glaciers didn't flatten out.
So it's all hilly and gorgeous and woodsy everywhere and just creeks and you
know,
it was just God damn it is fucking beautiful.
Just fucking beautiful and quiet and peaceful.
And I felt like just sitting there for an hour did me good.
Just like it cleaned me out somehow.
Like it cleaned my,
my spirit,
you know?
Yeah.
There you,
you mentioned weather earlier and we were talking about,
you know,
the,
the cleanliness of fear and it,
there's something about whether that I find deeply relaxing like strong,
like a storm or a tropical storm,
a hurricane.
You know,
I'm like one of those guys,
I would time myself to a tree and just like watch the hurricane come through and
do that.
They get hit in the face by a car that that's the downside of fucking tree comes
by and takes your head off.
You shouldn't do,
you can't duck.
Yeah.
But I agree with you though.
Like as long as I know it's not life threatening,
a good thunder showers beautiful.
Even if it is life threatening,
I mean that's even more cleansing cause it's good to be fucking terrified a
little bit.
It's good to,
it's,
I mean for me,
anything that reminds me of how insignificant I am is really liberating.
Yeah.
And the problem is when,
when I get caught up in my ego and you know,
the,
whatever the bullshit is that I need to deal with and Blah,
blah,
blah.
And I forget how,
you know,
it's like the football coach who,
doesn't,
isn't smart enough to know how little it all matters.
You know?
It's like I never want to forget how little it all matters cause then you're,
then you're screwed.
I agree with you a hundred.
I think it was really important.
I think as we were saying about whether that dealing with weather is,
it's important to just to know that you,
you're humbled by nature upon occasion.
It's one of the things I like about when it rains in la and everybody else to
go,
oh okay,
yeah,
this could happen to his people that complain about it.
But I love the fact that they're introduced to the reality of the fact that
you're living on a planet with an ecosystem and it's variable.
It's very variable,
right?
Yeah.
Something that that cuts through your,
I mean I still love it when the lights and,
yeah,
and you're,
you know,
the infrastructure that yeah,
your complacency.
Exactly.
I mean,
one of the cool things,
and I've lived in India for four months at a stretch,
and one of the cool things there is that electricity would go out like
constantly,
you know,
so cool.
Yeah.
No,
it's not terrible.
It sucks you.
Food goes bad.
Uh,
they're all covered in flies.
Me.
Keep me from going there,
please.
I ain't never been to India.
No,
no.
Dude,
you gotta gotta gotta hit him.
I don't know.
That's what's interesting.
I don't,
I,
I love Indian food.
I fucking love it.
Yeah.
There's a dish named after me,
lamb,
Rogan,
Josh.
Oh,
and it's not named after me.
It's just happens to happen.
I had that last night.
It's delicious.
And somebody's,
Oh fuck.
Somebody last night told me that story.
Showed me that recipe in her cookbook and said that something about the person
who named it got you confused with Seth Rogan or something or Josh somebody.
Is it an old days?
Yes.
Was that bullshit?
Fucking retarded.
Oh my God.
You're hanging out with a monkey that first.
That dish has been around forever.
Let's find out how long the lamb Rogan Josh.
I was,
I was hanging with this really sweet woman in Vancouver one night,
and a lay lady lay came on and she said,
do you know Dylan wrote that song for his dog?
And she said,
yeah,
he's dog's name was lady.
And he wrote the song for the dog.
Okay.
This is her ex boyfriend had told her that this is from Persia.
It's one of the signature recipes of Kashmiri cuisine.
Rogan means clarified butter or fat in Persian,
while Josh means heat,
hot,
boiling or passionate Rogan.
Josh dust means cooked in oil and intense heat and other interpretation of the
name.
Rogan Josh has delivered Deriv derived from the word Rogan,
meaning red color,
uh,
the same Indo European root that is the source of the French rogue and the
Spanish rogue Roho.
Uh,
and Josh meaning passion or heat.
So there you go.
So this is old shit man.
This is like,
it's named after.
No,
no,
she's an asshole.
She should do a Google search or force you fuck it spreads hardened incense.
It's not me or that beautiful Seth Rogan fellow,
which by the way,
uh,
I watched uh,
his last movie.
Um,
the,
this is the end and Holy Shit is that fun?
It is fun.
There are some,
there are some fucking funny,
funny,
funny moments in that movie,
but how good is Craig Robinson that Mike,
Sarah was my favorite thing.
Oh,
he was great.
To a blow job or the Beth.
How about Kenny powers?
Oh my God.
It's a fucking amazing.
The fun about all just taking the piss out of themselves.
That's what I love about it.
You know,
they're all like,
I love about Craig Robinson has a towel everywhere he goes and sweat so much,
which is so true about Craig in real life.
You know,
he's always got a towel on stage with him.
Oh,
that was really,
really funny.
Movie Moon.
It was a good,
did I ever tell you there's this one video of like a fight that broke out in
like a gymnasium and everyone used even used to have towels more back then
because like with a towel things kind of knew like and then like last 10 years
like rappers started having towels all the time and stuff and this whole thing
is new where they just carry around with a towel that all the time.
No,
never seen it yet.
There was this fight that broke out in this gymnasium and they showed the video
lasted to like everyone got out of the gymnasium and on the ground was just
towels and the stickers from people's hats.
Whole area looked like it was a joke.
That's hilarious.
A big rap battle with towels and stickers.
Yeah.
I remember when they used to wait like where the the tag on their hat hanging
from their hat.
Like Minnie Pearl from the old Opry choose your original gangster many curls
from,
from the Grand Ole Opry.
She always had a tag on her hat,
man.
I Dunno what that was about.
Did you hear about that?
That,
that waitress in New Jersey,
that's,
oh my God,
that's fucking gross story.
You know the story.
Uh,
not yet about the,
uh,
the lesbian woman.
She was working as a waitress in this nasty note.
Yeah.
She got some nasty note that said,
we are not going to leave a tip because we don't agree with your lifestyle.
Right.
It's a hoax.
No.
Yes.
Personally,
yes.
The family started getting shit family brought in the actual original receipt.
You know how you get a customer copy and a merchant copy?
Yeah.
Well the customer copy was the one that she left,
but the merchant copy,
she left blank.
You know,
sometimes people fuck up and they fill out the wrong one.
Well,
they had the customer copy,
they had a copy of it.
They like,
they saved it and the merchant copy,
I don't know if somebody's photo shopped it.
I Dunno what the fuck he can read,
print these out.
So all she did is just reprinted out and then write it on.
She wrote on it in a hoax to try to draw attention to herself and sending her
money.
Thousands and thousands of dollars that she was going to use and she was going
to send to something else.
And you know what I mean?
I don't know if who knows?
I mean,
we're accusing her of hoaxing it,
but it might've been something that her are her,
her staff did.
Right.
It could have been a hoax on her.
Yes.
We,
no one knows.
And so I think it's,
we shouldn't,
we shouldn't definitely not accuse someone or you know,
say that she did it or did she was a liar,
but somebody fucking hoax.
What's interesting is that,
I don't know if you heard the family said that the only thing they could think
of is that the host,
this is Dana is going to be,
or Dan's going to be your ho a waiter and be here in a second.
And then when she came up they go,
Oh,
you're definitely not a Dan,
you know,
or something like that.
Cause her real name's Dana.
And uh,
so she kind of might've took,
take it as like,
oh,
they're calling me a guy,
you know?
And that's why she got mad at these people.
Yeah.
But that still doesn't mean you should hope that and write a fake,
I mean,
so did they actually did leave her a tip?
20% or 18% of normal statements?
Yeah,
they left her like the right amount every month.
Me,
like five years ago,
I read this story in the International Herald Tribune about a guy,
this is relates to where we were saying earlier,
a rich guy,
he millionaire big house who decided to give it all up and uh,
you know,
give everything away and live a simple life cause that that was happy.
It would make them happier and the US in that.
Right.
So when I started working on civilized death,
I
found I had this clipping that I had kept for years and I,
so I googled the dude to see,
you know,
what's happened with this guy as he's still happy or is he getting another job?
What's going on?
Turns out it was the whole thing was a hoax.
Oh Wow.
He owed a bunch of money and he went and he figured out that he would get more
money if he auctioned his house.
So what he did was he said like,
and he went to a public relations company and they came up with this whole plan.
They're like,
he was going to renounce his wealth and all that,
but really behind the scenes,
he had to make money to pay off creditors,
whatever it was.
And the guys going around the world still giving talks,
charging lots of money to give,
talks about how wonderful it is to give up all your money.
It's all a fucking hoax.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
This family,
apparently,
not only would they not homophobic,
they actually wouldn't vote for governor Christie because he didn't agree with
gay marriage.
So his family was very progressive.
Right.
So it's like,
you know,
she fucked,
whoever did it fucked up.
Fuck the wrong people.
They just did something gross.
They did something gross and fake.
But that's the world that we live in,
man.
You know,
until we figure out how to tell whether or not people are lying,
we're going to be dealing with this nonsense for a long time.
Well,
she's the one that came out and said,
look what these people said and put it on her Instagram or whatever she did and,
and,
and it's actually a good point.
And so that,
that showed the wrong amount on there.
And so they have a credit card statement like going,
no,
this is the right amount.
Here is my actual copy receipt.
So she had to
have done it.
It must most likely,
unless someone tricked her and took the good bill away and then rode on the
other one,
a fake signature.
And when they gonna have to find out the signatures match and then rode on the
one with a fake signature,
find out who the fuck wrote that.
Like they have handwriting experts.
Yeah.
They could tell if it's a woman's writing or man's writing or transgender.
Hey,
easy.
A cabbie could be a cabbies writing challenge.
Yeah.
I don't know.
You know,
I think,
I think you're going to have bigots for sure.
You're always going to have bigots,
but you're also is going to have like people that are crying out for attention
and pretend the they've been a victim of bigotry.
You're going to have rape,
but you're also going to have false rape accusations too.
It's like that's one of the reasons why I'm,
I'm really against gender identity in the fact that not gender identity but
sticking with your gender like uniformly and prejudice Li like always I'm on
team penis,
you know?
I think that's ridiculous.
I think sticking with your race just as ridiculous,
sticking with your nationality,
equally ridiculous.
I've met fantastic people in England.
I've met some awesome folks in Canada.
It's stupid.
It's like to categorize people or to like I'm a fucking patriots fan and those
giants could suck it and it's the same thing.
You're doing the same thing and it's dumb and it's just as dumb on on all sides.
And until that's resolved,
you're going to always have this cloudy situations until it's impossible for
someone to rape a woman,
which is never going to happen probably until you know,
we figured out there's no,
I mean this is a lot of steps before there's any no violence and no rape is
going to be a lot of steps for,
there's no theft.
It's going to be probably,
we're not going to see it in our lifetime,
but it's possible and that's the only way we're going to have like real harmony
and these,
I don't know necessarily how much like pro vagina or pro men's rights groups,
I don't know how much those things fucking help anybody.
They create dialogue I guess,
but I think they also like they'd divide in a lot of ways and they,
you know,
when people hear the word feminist they almost automatically think,
oh she fucking hates men.
They're just a really in women and it creates like a rift.
When you heal men's rights organization,
what do you think?
I think misogynists I think fat,
Lazy Misogynists who women don't like.
So they come up with a bunch of reasons why women suck.
And that's not necessarily correct on either side,
but it's still,
that's the automatic stereotype that waitress who lied about it,
gay tip has told far worst laws.
She used to tell her that she had survived brain cancer,
that she did,
uh,
when in Afghanistan and all her people in her army thing blew up.
And she was the only survivor,
which she never even toured.
And Afghanistan kicked out of incriminating.
Go ahead.
Let's get off her.
I don't want to dwell on that.
Poor soul,
you know,
I agree with what you're saying.
I think that the source of all this,
all these problems is scale.
It gets back to population levels and,
and the size of communities,
right?
If you've ever heard of Dunbar's number's yeah.
So when you get above Dunbar's number,
other people become abstractions,
right?
It became like Stalin who said hundred and 50 people,
Stalin said one,
death is a tragedy.
1 million deaths is a statistic.
Right?
And so it's,
and it does become like that.
So if you're,
you know,
like in her case,
she might say,
well,
I wasn't lying to anybody.
I didn't know those people.
Right.
I mean,
you know,
people sending me money,
they can,
obviously they can spare it,
you know,
and I needed,
and you know,
you can make all sorts of excuses because you're not talking directly to the
person you fucked,
you know?
Whereas when,
and it's the same thing in the legal system,
you get minimum mandatory sentencing,
you know,
so all these people are going away to fucking prison for 15 years to life for,
and the judge is like this dude sitting right in front of me.
I know I can see this person as an individual.
He doesn't deserve this,
you know?
But because it's institutionalized,
I have to do it.
And so I,
I really think that as long as we're living in these massive societies where
we're constantly dealing with people we don't know in any personal way,
there's always going to be that sense of emptiness and the abuse of trust.
Yeah.
I think you're 100% right.
I think we have a real hard time dealing with large numbers of people.
You get this weird detachment,
like I was saying about Jimmy Norton living in this box with a thousand people
that he doesn't know this,
this.
And also I wanted to get back to this.
We were talking about earlier about New York after the twin towers.
We film fear factor in New York and I think it was 2002 or maybe 2003 at the
latest.
And it was palpable how friendly people were and what a change it had made and
what a sense of community.
We had a woman who is with us who may or may not have smoked some of my weed and
uh,
she was,
one of the crew and a May or may not have been ready for some of my weed and
Blacktown and actually fainted on the street.
And we had a catcher like,
uh,
we were all sitting around.
I'm like,
you guys want to get high?
Maybe allegedly.
I said that.
And we went outside and um,
she,
she literally lost consciousness.
So the firemen came and when the firemen came over,
first of all,
they could have been more friendly and uh,
you know,
they were really nice to her and everything,
but the amount of love the firemen were getting from people on the street waving
to them honking at the,
um,
you know,
like a set is yelling and shouting nice things to cross the street.
You know,
somebody yelled something about I love first responders or some,
something along those lines and they wave to them.
And there was like this,
this feeling of appreciation and camaraderie.
Think about the American soldiers going into France.
Yeah.
And World War II,
the amount of love they were again.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
man.
Yeah.
Save us from this fucking Har.
I mean,
it's real life and that's the thing.
Then we can go through an entire lifetime without ever really experiencing real
life.
We don't see death.
I mean,
I don't know how many dead bodies you've seen,
but you know,
I think my grandmother is the only dead body I ever saw and I got to kiss her on
the fucking lips,
which was pretty creepy.
I saw my grandfather.
Yeah,
same,
same sort of situation.
Do you ever,
you know this mortician ask a mortician,
uh,
Caitlin,
Caitlin Dodi,
she'd be a funny guests for you to or meet or just to hang out.
She's just like a hip,
young,
sexy mortician and she's got a show called ask a mortician that's like,
gets hundreds of thousands of hits,
a hip,
young,
sexy mortician.
Ask a mortician ask.
That sounds ridiculous.
I had her on my podcast,
she was fantastic.
She's,
she's just fascinated by death and uh,
know there she is.
She is pretty hot.
She's damn,
she's hot from mortician,
but still,
that's just so weird that she's doing.
And Her story is cool,
man.
How cool could it really be?
What she's,
I mean,
it's really cool because,
you know,
the thing is we come to these moments in our lives where we have to face death
and we get some creepy dude in a bad suit,
you know,
selling us overpriced by the way.
What's going on with a $12,000 hermetically sealed stainless steel coffin?
What the fuck are we saying?
Yeah.
We're saying we're ripping you off.
Joey Diaz has good line on that because it's one of his buddies that he went to
school with.
Uh,
his family owned a funeral parlor and a,
they were just pretty open about what a rip off it is and how they scam you and
how they get you in,
in the period where you're in great grief.
And they say,
you know,
wouldn't you like to represent your family in a very beautiful way and we can
offer this fantastic walnut lined coffin.
This is the finest Valore
interior,
finest.
The lure.
And you know,
all these people are,
yeah,
they're there.
They don't want to feel bad that they're not taking care of their loved ones.
So they spend insane amounts of money.
And then there's a scam where even if you want to,
um,
to cremate someone,
you still have to embalm the body.
So they have to embalm the body,
prepare it for preservation.
Know the embalming.
Kaitlin and I talked about this.
That's American.
Nobody else in ballroom spa.
Yeah.
This whole like take out the blood,
put in toothpaste that's American and you know where it came from.
Where?
Civil war really.
Yeah.
Because they wanted to,
so many guys are dying in their families wanted to bury the body back home on
the farm,
you know,
so the guy dies down in,
wherever Georgia,
they have to get the body back to Pennsylvania.
It's going to rot,
you know,
cause it's going in a wagon behind a horse or something.
So that's when they started the embalming things so they could get the bodies
back home and it's just wow.
It just took off and became an American tradition
and it became also one of those things where it becomes a part of the system,
you know,
once,
once something is in the system,
right.
It becomes an issue where it's really difficult to change that it becomes,
yeah.
It's like one of the problems with making drugs illegal.
It's like,
well,
okay,
what about all these people that make their living off arresting people for
drugs?
You know,
and that's one of the main issues with as far as lobbying is concerned,
is police guard or a prison guard unions,
right?
Prison guard unions spent a lot of money to make sure that certain drugs remain
legal
in the,
in the companies that make these private prisons.
Yes.
You know,
the state has to guarantee them in 98% occupancy.
So you got to come up with the bodies.
Oh my God,
that's so fucking crazy.
Or funny example of that is in Spanish.
Funny.
But you know,
the less tragic,
I guess,
example in Spain,
they've got an industry of dubbing films and TV shows.
So La and it's really advanced.
So like the guy who does woody Allen always does woody Allen.
So Spanish people associate that voice with Woody Allen.
And apparently it's a real art form.
Right.
Whereas in Portugal subtitles,
it's,
everything has been subtitled forever.
So there's no tradition of dubbing,
dubbing industry in Portugal.
So you go to Portugal,
everybody speaks English,
the guy checking you,
you know,
taking your money at the gas station speaks English because he grew up watching
American programming with Portuguese subtitles,
hearing the voice,
the voices speaking English.
Right.
Just pick it up in Spain,
nobody speaks English.
So people like me go there and make a lot of money teaching English because
they've got this stupid dubbing system.
So they're probably like two dozen,
three dozen people make a living doing this.
And they're completely fucking the entire country just so they don't lose their
jobs.
You know?
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
Hundreds of millions of euros spent if not billions on English classes and it's
completely unnecessary.
Just get rid of those 30 guys who make a living dubbing.
It's,
I'll have to learn English or not.
Well they won't have to learn it cause they'll,
they'll grow up watching it on TV and hearing it.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's wild.
There's a lot of weird things like that where something becomes a part of the
system and even though it's illogical,
it just remains because it's attribute board it right in front of you.
Courtney folks don't know.
Explain that well the keyboard,
the,
the layout of the keyboard,
the placement of the letters is the way it is because of frequency of use.
And so they tried to,
to space the letters out so that you wouldn't hit two letters that were next to
each other that we're,
the arm came up on the typewriter so that the arms would tangle.
So they tried to make it so that the arms that came up would be spaced out.
So they laid out the keyboard that way.
So it's a very inefficient way to have a keyboard because it's not,
it's based upon the demands of a machine that no longer exists.
It's not based upon ease of use,
which I mean really that's a metaphor for society in general.
This is what I've been saying the whole time,
you know,
like the interest of the corporation,
the interests of these institutions supersede the interest of the person.
So people always say to me when I get into these arguments about human nature,
like yeah,
but we're people we can decide,
you know,
we can free will and Yada Yada Ya.
But you know,
you do want a shoe that's more or less shaped like a foot,
right?
If your shoes strays too far from the shape of a foot,
you're fucked.
Yeah.
And so the,
yeah,
the keyboard is a good example of that.
They made one that's like,
oh yeah,
there's a much more efficient key layout.
But the problem is you would have to,
first of all,
you'd have to change your key.
You'd have to bring it to a place and get it done.
Or you get a,
if you have a,
an actual external keyboard,
you can get it and learn it.
But it's,
it's really weird and you'd have to relearn.
Yeah.
So there's this vested interest is like,
I can type pretty goddamn fast and I don't have to look at it.
I can just do it like while I'm talking to you.
As long as I feel those little nubs on the f and the J,
I'm good to go.
Yeah.
But I know where the system is.
I know where everything is.
Yeah.
Apparently though it's not the best way.
And the other way is like statistically quite a bit faster.
It's like x,
Esperanto.
What's that?
Esperanto is this,
um,
like a,
an artificial language that was invented I think late 19th century.
Not Ebonics.
Do you know that I,
on my resume I have that USP bottlenecks to English translator.
That's a good one.
I have been paid.
Really?
I have been paid to translate from Ebonics.
Danglish so you like that lady on the movie airplane?
This friend of mine was,
uh,
how much do you get paid for that?
I got paid pretty heavy,
whatever it was back when I was teaching English in Spain.
I was living in Barcelona and this friend of mine was a Hispanic woman,
was a translator for an independent film festival,
but they have every year in Barcelona called Ian Edit.
And,
uh,
so she calls me up and she says,
Hey,
Chris,
do you,
do you understand black people?
And I thought she meant conceptually.
Yeah.
I was like,
yeah,
you get it.
Definitely some,
you know,
whatever.
Uh,
as much as I understand anyway.
And she's like,
no,
no.
The way they talk,
like,
Oh yeah,
whatever.
So the story was that that year the films were all about the original,
um,
bebop guys,
the origins of hip hop in Brooklyn in the 70s,
I guess,
and Delta Blues Man.
And so the Spanish translators who spoke English very,
very well would listen to these dudes and they couldn't understand what they
were saying.
So they had me come down the first,
they had called a black guy,
but he was British and he didn't understand them,
right?
So then they're like,
well,
I know a white guy,
but he's American.
So I,
my job was to go down and sit there next to a translator,
watch this DVD with the pause thing and just,
you know,
pause.
They're like,
you know,
the dude would be like,
yeah,
we're up in my crib.
And it's like a stop light.
That means they went back to his apartment and I continued,
I didn't even have to translate it into Spanish.
I also was the in house editor and translator for the biggest porn company in
the world.
Whoa.
Private.
Yeah,
inhouse translator and editor.
Yeah.
So you had to translate American porn to ain't to Spanish.
I try it again.
What I pretty much stayed in that job was translate from bad English to better
English because they had someone else who would like do the rough translation
and then they'd email me the documents and I just had to go through and clean it
up.
And they're funny things.
Like for example,
in German tail,
the word tail refers to penis.
So I remember one of the first ones I was translating it was like for some
hardcore porn mag,
you know,
and,
and there were two dudes wagging their tails.
Yeah.
And one of the dudes are,
the woman looked at the dudes and it was and was like,
Oh,
you guys have nice tails or a nice tail.
And I was like,
Whoa,
wait a minute.
An English Tales,
the,
you know,
the woman.
It's completely different.
But anyway,
that was,
that was a weird gig.
That was,
that was the Gig that strangely enough led me to meet Paul locaway.
Yo,
the Brazilian writer,
you know him,
he wrote the alchemist,
like the best selling book in the history of humanity.
What is the alchemist about the alchemist is this,
um,
is a story about,
uh,
the product prodigal son.
It's,
it's what Joseph Campbell called the hero with a thousand faces,
right?
It's a guy born in southern Spain.
Uh,
has,
goes on a quest,
goes through northern Africa,
meets all these characters and their,
give them challenges and tests and things.
And then he goes through the test and he goes back home and he finds the
treasure he was looking for all the time.
Right.
The Odyssey.
It's the same story.
It's not a good book.
I'm not recommending it.
It just sold more books than any book since the Bible.
Really?
Yeah.
It's a huge bestseller.
Paul Oakway use an industry like you go to a bookstore,
there'll be a Paulo keyway yo stand with,
but they're not good books there.
It's new age bullshit.
You know,
it takes the oldest story in the world.
Retells it and calls it knew and loved.
It makes a lot of money.
They do this knowing that something's wrong and searching for an answer and
finding one that has the most mystical qualities attached to it.
That's new age bullshit,
isn't it?
It is.
Do you know a Jamie and Swiss?
The Magician?
No,
it was interviewing him.
He's,
he's like the world's most famous closeup magician.
He'll do shit in front of you on a table that will blow your fucking mind.
Anyway,
he said the worst.
He said smart people are the easiest to trick.
Really?
Yeah.
Because they're there.
Predict their attention is predictable.
You know where they're going to look.
You can pull their attention where you want.
They're well trained.
Kids are really tough cause kids will look where they're not supposed to look.
And he said he hates doing magic for new agers because they already believe in
all this bullshit.
So it's like
you already believe that Crystal's going to save you that you know what I do?
Is it really going to impress you?
Oh,
it's like,
yeah.
It's like selling fake real estate to mentally handicapped people.
Yeah.
There's no challenge.
What are you doing there?
That's not a skill.
It's like what Bernie Madoff did.
That's Goddamn scam.
The very sophisticated scam and probably there's a lot of satisfaction.
Tricia tricking all these really smart people to give me your money.
Yeah.
But it's also a very simple,
right.
You know,
warm in with more money.
You know what works for him.
Even though people were looking at the numbers,
this is fucking,
this doesn't even make any sense.
Like where's this money coming from?
Like doesn't make any sense.
You can't do that trick on someone who's not greedy.
It's true,
right?
Yeah.
Somebody Frugal and smart and conservative,
they were like,
Ooh,
this does not seem like it makes sense.
I'm going to get out.
I don't need it.
But Spielberg is like,
listen,
I'm telling you,
the guy's giving me 20% of my investment.
So many people lost money with that guy too.
Like big,
big,
big people.
Lots of fucking money.
Lots of money.
Yeah.
I was working in the 80s after Alaska if they went there two years and then I
got this job and the dye lived there for two whole years.
Well,
two summers I worked on in a cannery the first year and on a boat.
Salmon.
Yeah.
What do they do?
How do they do that?
They boil the fish and then just chopping the cube.
Oh Man.
It was,
it was,
it was very intense.
I worked in Kenai,
Kenai packers still remember him.
Respect.
Uh,
and I lived in my tent up on the bluff.
You lived in a tent?
Yeah.
All summer.
You got like a individual tent,
like a small town,
big tent where a bunch of people living in it.
It was just my 10 no,
it was a,
it was a three man,
a geodesic dome tent and at one point we got eight people in there having the
party.
Yeah,
that was pretty fun in the rain.
We all had to sit with our legs over each other,
you know,
in a circle.
And we're passing the wine and the joints around in the circle.
Oh Wow.
And uh,
playing footsies,
that was the first time I ever saw anyone light a fart.
And it was a historic moment in my life.
I've never seen that.
I've seen,
I started a video online.
Nope.
It does,
it eliminates the stink.
Yeah.
Kills the methane,
right?
Yeah.
And uh,
so I was living there.
So the way the way it works is the fish come in and uh,
you know,
you can get jobs because when the fish come in,
they have to process them fast because they're rotting.
Right.
So the fish come in,
uh,
they go through this,
they come off the boats,
they go through this machine,
this big clanking machine that they called the Chink.
And I thought it was called the chink cause it like,
you know,
changing,
changing.
And one day I asked one of the foreman and he said,
oh no,
it's called the chink because Chinese used to do that job
and the job was to rip off the head and,
and get the you as much of the guts as possible.
So then the,
the fish go onto these conveyor belts and they come down the slime line and
that's where I was.
I was a slime monkey the first year.
So you stand there,
you've got it's piping cold water spraying on a cutting board.
You're wearing rain gear,
uh,
ear plugs because it's so loud.
You got a knife in your hand,
gloves and you're just gutting the fish all day.
You're getting what the Chink missed.
Sometimes it bid missed everything.
So you have to take off the head,
the fins,
get the guts,
get the blood line off the spine and the back,
and then you put it on.
You put all that guts,
all that stuff into a shoot,
which I later learned is goes into tanks that are sold to pharmaceutical
companies because the fat from the internal organs and the head of the salmon is
the base for a lot of cosmetics.
And then the other,
the,
the fish,
assuming the fishes in decent condition goes onto another conveyor belt and then
it goes down into the canning section where it's chopped and placed in these
cans.
So it's just chopped rights.
Here you have lived some really crazy adventures.
You've had a pretty wild and and broad life.
Well that was the point,
right?
I wanted,
I mean,
when I was 20 I was like,
you know,
fuck it,
I'm going to die someday.
But it's,
you know,
romantic that you actually like engineered that,
a lot of people don't,
you know,
they said maybe they have a rich crazy life,
but as,
because they were an alcoholic and they were running from the law,
if you like,
you made a conscious decision to have this adventure.
Yeah.
It was definitely intentional and I mean it helped that I didn't want to have
kids.
Right.
So that removed that whole area of,
of,
of problem for me.
And it also helped them.
My parents were sort of upper middle class and really good people and they were,
you know,
the only thing my dad said when that first year in Alaska,
I call it,
I said,
look,
I'm going,
I'm going to Japan.
I'm just like forget college,
I'm,
I'm alive.
You know.
Also about the time I discovered acid by that help,
the wonder connection maybe.
And my dad was like,
look Chris,
you know,
I'll support you in anything you do,
but please for me,
go back to school,
Finish,
get your degree because it's going to be so hard to go back later.
So for my dad and really to this day,
that's like the only thing he's ever stepped in and said,
please trust me on this.
I went back to school,
but I said,
I'm not going to live in the dorms.
I'm not cause I went to this school full of rich spoiled ass holes.
I mean,
George Bushes niece was in my class,
the air to the Spalding fortune and was in my class.
Um,
so I lived in my tent in the woods behind the art museum.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I love talking to you,
man.
It's so much fun.
We're out of time,
but we can do this all day.
Do like a hundred times a year.
You got a gig tonight,
right?
Yes.
We're at the ice.
It's sold out though.
So go fuck yourself folks.
If you're trying to buy a ticket to late tough shit,
you snooze,
you lose.
I was going to ask for one.
You can get in.
I human.
Come on son.
You sit on my lap.
It's rose petals.
Listen,
he's going to look at you like you looked at that and I call on the plane.
Feed each other routes,
penalties.
Think about breastfeeding on planes.
Um,
let's do this again man.
Anytime Dunkin in here.
I was trying to,
well,
Dunkin,
who knows.
We will.
We'll talk about that off the year.
Great.
Duncan,
Danielle Lee,
the whole,
yeah,
yeah.
Daniela [inaudible] came on.
We would've been doing that more lately.
Having like a couple of people on like we had Brian Cowen and Tom Rhodes on last
week.
I had,
um,
Dan Carlin and Daniella Bolelli.
That was a really fun,
so,
uh,
we'll do this again.
Yeah,
I always play anytime.
I really dawn,
please buy it.
Go buy it.
It's a fucking fantastic book.
And uh,
if you thinking about get breaking up with your relationship,
it will push you over the edge.
I'll tell you that.
They'll give me that extra push you might need if you were in a bad one to be
free and they go fucking with no underwear and Alaska.
Oh Hey.
Uh,
we will see you tonight.
If you want to come down,
it'd be tonight is a red band,
Matt Full Tron,
Sam Tripoli,
Brian Callen,
dom Irrera and me.
We're going to have a hell of a show.
Was supposed to be Greg Fitzsimmons but unfortunately he has to pick up his mom
at the airport.
But Greg will be here on the podcast this Friday,
so we should have a good time as well.
And Greg has a new special out that I listened to on the way home from the
Irvine Improv a couple of months ago.
And it's really fucking funny,
really good stuff.
So,
uh,
we will see you soon.
My friends mad.
Love to all of you.
Thanks to Carbonite for sponsoring the podcast.
Go to carbonite.com type in the offer code,
J r e for a free trial.
Thanks also to ting.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save yourself some money on an awesome company,
a company that really does have a,
an ethical solution to all your cell phone needs.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com go to o n n I t use the code name Rogan and
save yourself some money.
But this Friday we have an even better deal.
This is black Friday and shit's going to get crazy.
Save massive amounts of money,
25% off soft men's,
15% off foods,
10% off fitness packages,
plus an additional 5% off orders,
over 150 or 10% off orders,
over $250.
So for big orders,
that's like 35% off supplements and 20% off fitness.
It's a very powerful,
and uh,
that's it.
You got something going on?
Oh yeah.
This weekend I'll be with Joey Diaz and a San Diego at the American comedy Co's.
Saturday I'm going to be at his show,
but he has shows Friday and Saturday.
And then December 11th I'll be in San Jose Improv at the comedy palace with
Brody Stevens and Sam Tripoli and a probably a bunch of other comics there.
Good googly Moodley.
You can't miss it.
A December 13th I'm at the Crest Theater in Sacramento with the lovely twink
Tony Hinchcliffe.
And then on the 27th I'm at the Mirage Hotel in Las Vegas,
Nevada with Joey Diaz and Brian Cowen.
Shit shall be crazy.
All right.
We love the fuck out of people and we will see you soon.
Keep it together,
bitches.
We're all in this as one big kiss.